JOHN: ALL RIGHT, SO TONIGHT'S
DEBATE ABOUT TO START.
YOU CAN WATCH ON BLOOMBERG
TELEVISION AND TWITTER.
WE WILL BE BACK WITH ANALYSIS
STARTING AT 10:30 P.M.
CHRIS WALLACE IS ON STAGE NOW,
GIVING THE AUDIENCE THE HOUSE
RULES.
FINAL THOUGHTS, MARK?
MARK: IF DONALD HAS A PATH, HE
MUST WIN THIS DEBATE DECISIVELY.
HE MUST CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF
THEIR RACE, AND MANY PEOPLE
AROUND HIM KNOW THAT.
WE WILL SEE.
JOHN: STEVE SCHMIDT THOUGHT
DONALD TRUMP HAD GIVEN A BAD
PERFORMANCE IN THE FIRST AND
SECOND DEBATE.
HE THINKS THE RACE IS OVER.
THE ONLY POSSIBLE WAY IT COULD
NOT BE OVER IS IF HE GAVE A
PERFORMANCE TONIGHT AS GOOD AS
IT WAS BAD IN HIS FIRST
PERFORMANCE.
THIS IS THE LAST FORMAL EVENT.
THEY WILL BOTH APPEAR IN
MANHATTAN ON THURSDAY, BUT NO
OTHER EVENT WILL BRING THE TWO
OF THEM TOGETHER.
JOHN: WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
OCTOBER SURPRISES ALREADY.
GIVEN THE DAILY OCTOBER
SURPRISES, WE COULD HAVE MORE.
ALWAYS A LOT OF TENSION AND
PRESSURE IN A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN,.
THIS PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IS
NEGATIVE AND THEY ARE EXPECTING
IT TO FOLLOW THE FORM OF THE
FIRST TWO.
JOHN: IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT
DONALD TRUMP WANTED TO BRING THE
ACCUSERS INTO THE HOLE AND PUT
THEM IN A PLACE WHERE BILL
CLINTON HAD TO WALK PAST THEM.
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN WANTED TO
AVOID ANYTHING FURTHER ON DONALD
TRUMP'S PART.
THIS TIME, HE DOES HAVE SARAH
PALIN HERE AND BARACK OBAMA'S
HALF-BROTHER, A STRANGE CHOICE,
BUT THERE IS SOME REASON TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT THE THINGS THAT
DONALD TRUMP MIGHT TRY.
MARK: IT WILL BE A 90-MINUTE
SESSION THAT MIGHT GO OVER A
LITTLE BIT.
CHRIS WALLACE IS THE MODERATOR
FOR THE ENTIRE 90 MINUTES.
THE CANDIDATES HAVE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF LEEWAY TO BRING UP
THINGS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT.
DONALD TRUMP CAME INTO THE SPIN
ROOM AFTER THE FIRST DEBATE, NOT
AFTER THE SECOND DEBATE, AND NO
CLEAR WORD ON WHETHER HE WILL
COME IN TONIGHT.
WE WILL BE BACK AFTER THE DEBATE
WITH A FULL WRAPUP ANALYSIS AND
HOPEFULLY SOME REACTION FROM THE
CAMPAIGNS ON WHAT IS THE FINAL
DEBATE OF THE SERIES OF THREE.
JOHN: ONE TOPIC THAT HAS NOT
BEEN ADDRESSED THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY HEAR ABOUT IT TONIGHT,
IMMIGRATION, AND WE'VE NOT HAD
ANYTHING ABOUT IT IN THE FIRST
TWO DEBATES.
I WILL BE INTERESTING TO HEAR
THAT DEBATE TONIGHT.
MARK: BOTH CANDIDATES TO
STRONGLY AND HAVE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT VIEWS.
I THINK CHRIS WALLACE'S HAD THE
BENEFIT OF WATCHING THE FIRST
TWO DEBATES AND TO CONSIDER
WHERE MAYBE THE CANDIDATES ARE
VULNERABLE.
PRESUMABLY DONALD TRUMP WILL
IMPROVE.
WE WILL SEE.
SO, THE FINAL PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE IS ABOUT TO BEGIN IN LAS
VEGAS.
JOHN AND I WILL BE BACK WHEN
INS.
-- ENDS.
CHRIS WALLACE IS READY TO BEGIN
THE NIGHT.
MR. WALLACE: GOOD EVENING FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF NEVADA LAS
VEGAS.
I AM CHRIS WALLACE OF FOX NEWS.
I WELCOME YOU TO THE THIRD AND
FINAL 2016 PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE
BETWEEN SECRETARY OF STATE
HILLARY CLINTON AND DONALD J.
TRUMP.
THIS TODAY IS SPONSORED BY THE
COMMISSION ON PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATES.
THE COMMISSION HAS DESIGNED THE
FORMAT, SIX ROUGHLY 15 MINUTES
SEGMENTS WITH TWO-MINUTE ANSWERS
FOR THE FIRST QUESTION, THEN
OPEN DISCUSSION FOR THE REST OF
EACH SEGMENT.
BOTH CAMPAIGNS HAVE AGREED TO
THOSE RULES.
FOR THE RECORD, I DECIDED THE
TOPICS AND THE QUESTIONS IN EACH
TOPIC.
NONE OF THOSE QUESTIONS HAVE
ENSURED WITH THE COMMISSION OR
THE TWO CANDIDATES.
THE AUDIENCE IN THE HALL HAS
PROMISED TO REMAIN SILENT, NO
CHEERS, BLUES, OR OTHER
INTERRUPTIONS SO WE CAN FOCUS ON
WHAT THE CANDIDATES HAVE TO SAY.
NO NOISE EXCEPT RIGHT NOW AS WE
WELCOME THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE
FOR PRESIDENT, SECRETARY
CLINTON, AND THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT, MR.
TRUMP.
[APPLAUSE]
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON,
MR. TRUMP, WELCOME.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
THE FIRST TOPIC IS THE SUPREME
COURT.
YOU BOTH TALKED BRIEFLY ABOUT
THE COURT IN THE LAST DEBATE,
BUT I WANT TO DRILL DOWN ON THIS
BECAUSE THE NEXT PRESIDENT WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE AT LEAST ONE
APPOINTMENT, AND LIKELY TO-THREE
APPOINTMENTS, WHICH MEANS YOU
WILL IN EFFECT DETERMINED THE
BALANCE OF THE COURT FOR WHAT
COULD BE THE NEXT QUARTER
CENTURY.
FIRST OF ALL, WHERE DO YOU WANT
TO SEE THE COURT TAKE THE
COUNTRY, AND SECONDLY, WHAT IS
YOUR VIEW ON HOW THE
CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED?
DO THE FOUNDER'S WORDS MEAN WHAT
THEY SAY OR IS IT A LIVING
DOCUMENT TO BE APPLIED FLEXIBLY
ACCORDING TO CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES?
IN THIS SEGMENT, SECRETARY
CLINTON YOU GO FIRST.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
MRS. CLINTON: THANK YOU, CHRIS.
THANK YOU TO UNLV FOR HOSTING
US.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE SUPREME
COURT, IT RAISES THE CENTRAL
ISSUE IN THIS ELECTION, NAMELY
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY ARE WE
GOING TO BE, WHAT KIND OF
OPPORTUNITIES WILL WE PROVIDE
FOR OUR CITIZENS, WHAT KINDS OF
RIGHTS WILL AMERICANS HAVE, AND
I FEEL STRONGLY THAT THE SUPREME
COURT NEEDS TO STAND ON THE SIDE
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT ON
THE SIDE OF THE POWERFUL
CORPORATIONS AND THE WEALTHY.
FOR ME, THAT MEANS THAT WE NEED
A SUPREME COURT THAT WILL STAND
UP ON BEHALF OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS,
ON BEHALF OF THE RIGHTS OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY, THAT WILL STAND
UP AND SAY NO TO CITIZENS
UNITED, A DECISION THAT HAS
UNDERMINED THE ELECTION SYSTEM
IN OUR COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THE
WAY IT PERMITS A DARK,
UNACCOUNTABLE MONEY TO COME INTO
OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
I HAVE MAJOR DISAGREEMENTS WITH
MY OPPONENT ABOUT THESE ISSUES
AND OTHERS THAT WILL BE BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT.
I FEEL THAT AT THIS POINT IN OUR
COUNTRY'S HISTORY, IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT REVERSE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY, THAT WE NOT
REVERSE BROPHY WAY, -- ROVE
VERSUS WADE, THAT WE STAND UP
AGAINST CITIZENS UNITED, FOR THE
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE IN THE
WORKPLACE, THAT WE STAND UP AND
BASICALLY SAY THAT THE SUPREME
COURT SHOULD REPRESENT ALL OF
US.
THAT IS HOW I SEE THE COURT, AND
THE KIND OF PEOPLE I WOULD BE
LOOKING TO NOMINATE TO THE COURT
WOULD BE IN THE GREAT TRADITION
OF STANDING UP TO THE POWERFUL,
STANDING UP ON BEHALF OF OUR
RIGHTS AS AMERICANS, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
I WOULD HOPE THE SENATE WOULD DO
ITS JOB AND CONFIRM THE NOMINEE
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS SENT TO
THEM.
THAT IS THE WAY THE CONSTITUTION
FUNDAMENTALLY SHOULD OPERATE.
THE PRESIDENT NOMINATES, AND
THEN THE SENATE ADVISES AND
CONSENTS OR NOT, BUT GOES
FORWARD WITH THE PROCESS.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP, SAME
QUESTION.
WHERE DO YOU WANT TO SEE THE
COURT TAKE THE COUNTRY AND HAVE
YOU BELIEVE THE CONSTITUTION
SHOULD BE INTERPRETED?
MR. TRUMP: FIRST OF ALL, IT IS
GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
THE SUPREME COURT IS WHAT IT IS
ALL ABOUT.
OUR COUNTRY IS SO, SO, IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT JUSTICES.
SOMETHING HAPPENED RECENTLY
WHERE JUSTICE GINSBURG MADE SOME
VERY, VERY INAPPROPRIATE
STATEMENTS TOWARDS ME AND
TOWARDS A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
PEOPLE, MANY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
THAT I REPRESENT, AND SHE WAS
FORCED TO APOLOGIZE, AND
APOLOGIZE SHE DID, BUT THESE
WERE STATEMENTS THAT SHOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN MADE.
WE NEED TO SUPREME COURT THAT IN
MY OPINION IS GOING TO UPHOLD
THE SECOND AMENDMENT AND ALL
AMENDMENTS CAN, BUT THE SECOND,
WHICH IS UNDER ABSOLUTE SIEGE, I
BELIEVE, IF MY OPPONENT SHOULD
WIN THIS RACE, WHICH I TRULY
DON'T THINK WILL HAPPEN, WE WILL
HAVE A SECOND AMENDMENT WHICH
WILL BE A VERY, VERY SMALL
REPLICA OF WHAT IT IS RIGHT NOW,
BUT I FEEL IT IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE UPHOLD BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT IT IS UNDER
SUCH TRAUMA.
I FEEL THAT JUSTICE IS THAT I AM
GOING TO, AND I HAVE NAMED 20 OF
THEM, THE JUSTICES THAT I'M
GOING TO APPOINT WILL BE
PRO-LIFE.
THEY WILL HAVE A CONSERVATIVE
BENT, THEY WILL PROTECT THE THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEY ARE GREAT SCHOLARS IN ALL
CASES AND PEOPLE OF TREMENDOUS
RESPECT.
THEY WILL INTERPRET THE
CONSTITUTION THE WAY THE
FOUNDERS WANTED IT INTERPRETED,
AND I BELIEVE THAT IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
JUSTICES APPOINTED THAT DECIDE
WHAT THEY WANT TO HEAR.
IT IS ALL ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION
, AND SO IMPORTANT, THE
CONSTITUTION, THE WEIGHT IT WAS
MEANT TO BE, AND THOSE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I WOULD APPOINT.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP, THANK
YOU WE HAVE 10 MINUTES FOR AN
OPEN DISCUSSION.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON TWO ISSUES
THAT IN FACT WITH THE JUSTICES
THAT YOU NAME COULD CHANGE THE
EXISTING LAW OF THE LAND.
FIRST, IS ONE THAT YOU MENTION,
WHICH IS GUNS.
SECRETARY CLINTON, YOU SAID LAST
YEAR "THE SUPREME COURT IS WRONG
ON THE SECOND AMENDMENT."
AND NOW IN FACT, THE COURT RULED
THERE IS A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO BEAR ARMS, BUT A RIGHT THAT
IS REASONABLY LIMITED.
THOSE WERE THE WORDS OF THE
JUDGE, AND SNEEZE FOR LEAH, WHO
WROTE THE DECISION.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT?
MRS. CLINTON: FIRST OF ALL, I
SUPPORT THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
I LIVED IN ARKANSAS FOR 18 YEARS
AND REPRESENTED UPSTATE NEW YORK
AND RESPECT THE TRADITION OF A
GUN OWNERSHIP THAT GOES BACK TO
THE FOUNDING OF OUR COUNTRY, BUT
I ALSO BELIEVE THERE CAN BE AND
MUST BE REASONABLE REGULATION.
BECAUSE I SUPPORT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT DOES NOT MEAN THAT I
WANT PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE
GUNS TO BE ABLE TO THREATEN YOU,
KILL YOU OR MEMBERS OF YOUR
FAMILY, AND SO WHEN I THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO, WE
HAVE 33,000 PEOPLE A YEAR WHO
DIE FROM GUNS.
I THINK WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS, TO CLOSE THE
ONLINE LOOPHOLE, CLOSE THE GUN
SHOW LOOPHOLE, OTHER MATTERS
THAT I THINK ARE SENSIBLE, THE
KIND OF REFORMS THAT WOULD MAKE
A DIFFERENCE THAT ARE NOT IN ANY
WAY CONFLICTING WITH THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
YOU MENTIONED THE HELLER
DECISION, AND WHAT I WOULD SAY
YOU REFERENCED IS THAT I
DISAGREED WITH THE WAY THE COURT
APPLIED THE SECOND AMENDMENT IN
THAT CASE.
WHAT THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
WAS TRYING TO DO WAS TO PROTECT
TODDLERS FROM GUNS, AND SO THEY
WANTED PEOPLE WITH GUNS TO
SAFELY STORE THEM, AND THE COURT
DID NOT ACCEPT THAT REASONABLE
REGULATION, BUT THEY HAVE
ACCEPTED MANY OTHERS, SO I NEED
SEE NO CONFLICT.
MR. WALLACE: THE BIPARTISAN OPEN
DEBATE COALITION GOT MILLIONS OF
VOTES ON QUESTIONS TO ASK HERE,
AND THIS WAS IN FACT ONE OF THE
TOP QUESTIONS THEY GOT.
HOW WILL YOU ENSURE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT IS PROTECTED?
YOU JUST HEARD SECRETARY
CLINTON'S ANSWER.
THAT SHE PERSUADE YOU THAT WHILE
YOU MAY DISAGREE ON REGULATION,
THAT SHE IN FACT SUPPORTS A
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT TO BEAR
ARMS?
>> THE DECISION WAS VERY STRONG
AND SHE WAS EXTREMELY ANGRY
ABOUT IT, I WATCHED, AND SHE WAS
ANGRY, UPHELD, AND JUSTICE
SCALIA WAS SO INVOLVED IN IT WAS
A WELL-CRAFTED DECISION, BUT
HILLARY WAS EXTREMELY UPSET,
EXTREMELY ANGRY, AND PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVED IN THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, BELIEVED IN IT
STRONGLY, WERE UPSET WITH WHAT
SHE HAD TO SAY.
MR. WALLACE: LET ME BRING IN
SECRETARY CLINTON.
WHERE YOU EXTREMELY UPSET?
MRS. CLINTON: I WAS UPSET
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY DOZENS OF
TODDLERS INJURE THEMSELVES AND
KILL PEOPLE WITH GUNS BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERYONE WHO
HAS LOADED GUNS IN THEIR HOMES
TAKES APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS,
BUT THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT I
RESPECT THE SECOND AMENDMENT,
THAT I ALSO BELIEVE THERE IS AN
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS.
THAT IS NOT IN CONFLICT WITH
SENSIBLE COMMONSENSE REGULATION,
AND LOOK, I UNDERSTAND THAT
DONALD HAS BEEN STRONGLY
SUPPORTED BY THE NRA, THE GUN
LOBBY IS ON HIS SIDE, RUNNING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF ADS
AGAINST ME, AND I REGRET THAT,
BECAUSE WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IS FOR PEOPLE TO COME TOGETHER
AND SAY OF COURSE WE ARE GOING
TO PROTECT AND DEFEND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, BUT WERE GOING TO DO
IT IN A WAY THAT TRIES TO SAVE
SOME OF THESE 33,000 LIVES THAT
WE LOSE EVERY YEAR.
MR. WALLACE: LET ME BRING MR.
TRUMP BACK INTO IT.
IN FACT, YOU OPPOSE ANY LIMITS
ON ASSAULT WEAPONS, ANY LIMITS
ON HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
YOU SUPPORT A NATIONAL RIGHT TO
CARRY LAW.
MR. TRUMP: LET ME TELL YOU
BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER, IN
CHICAGO, WHICH IS THE TOUGHEST
GUN LAWS IN THE UNITED STATES,
PROBABLY YOU COULD SAY BY FAR,
THEY HAVE MORE GUN VIOLENCE THAN
ANY OTHER CITY, SO WE HAVE THAT
TOUGHEST LAWS AND TREMENDOUS GUN
VIOLENCE.
I AM A VERY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT, AND I
DON'T KNOW IF HILLARY WAS SAYING
IT IN A SARCASTIC MANNER, BUT I
AM PROUD TO HAVE THE ENDORSEMENT
OF THE NRA, THE EARLIEST
ENDORSEMENT THEY HAVE GIVEN TO
ANYBODY WHO HAS RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
WE WILL APPOINT JUSTICES, THIS
IS THE BEST WAY TO HELP THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
WE WILL APPOINT JUSTICES WHO
FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, THAT WILL NOT DO
DAMAGE TO THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
MR. WALLACE: LET'S PICK UP ON
ANOTHER ISSUE WHICH DIVIDES YOU
AND THE JUSTICES THAT WHOEVER
INSECT WHEN IN THE SELECTION OF
POINTS COULD HAVE A DRAMATIC
AFFECT THERE, AND THAT'S THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION.
MR. TRUMP, YOU ARE PRO-LIFE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU SPECIFICALLY
IF YOU WANT THE COURT AND THE
JUSTICES YOU WILL NAME TO
OVERTURN ROE VERSUS WADE, A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO ABORTION?
MR. TRUMP: IF THAT WOULD HAPPEN
BECAUSE I AM PRO-LIFE AND WOULD
APPOINT PRO-LIFE JUDGES, I THINK
THAT WOULD GO BACK TO THE
INDIVIDUAL STATES.
MR. WALLACE: I AM ASKING YOU
SPECIFICALLY.
WHAT I'M ASKING YOU, SIR, IS DO
YOU WANT TO SEE THE COURT
OVERTURNED, YOU JUST YOU WANT TO
SEE THE COURT OVERTURN IT?
MR. TRUMP: IF WE PUT ANOTHER 2-3
JUSTICES ON, THAT IS WHAT WILL
HAPPEN, AND THAT WILL HAPPEN
AUTOMATICALLY IN MY OPINION
BECAUSE I AM PUTTING PRO-LIFE
JUSTICES ON THE COURT.
IT WILL GO BACK TO STATES, AND
IN THE STATES WILL MAKE A
DETERMINATION.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON?
MRS. CLINTON: I STRONGLY SUPPORT
ROE VERSUS WADE, WHICH
GUARANTEES THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO A WOMAN TO MAKE THE
MOST INTIMATE, MOST DIFFICULT IN
MANY CASES DECISIONS ABOUT HER
HEALTH CARE THAT ONE CAN IMAGINE
, AND IN THIS CASE, IT IS NOT
ONLY ABOUT ROE VERSUS WADE, IT
IS ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW IN AMERICA, SO MANY STATES
ARE PUTTING VERY STRINGENT
REGULATIONS ON WOMEN THAT BLOCK
THEM FROM EXERCISING THAT CHOICE
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY ARE
DEFUNDING PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
WHICH OF COURSE PROVIDES ALL
KINDS OF CANCER SCREENINGS AND
OTHER BENEFITS FOR WOMEN IN OUR
COUNTRY.
DONALD HAS SAID HE IS IN FAVOR
OF DEFUNDING PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
HE EVEN SUPPORTED SHUTTING THE
GOVERNMENT DOWN TO DEFUND PLANT.
I WILL DEFEND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
I WILL DEFEND ROE VERSUS WADE.
I WOULD DEFEND WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO
MAKE THEIR OWN HEALTH CARE
DECISIONS.
WE HAVE COME TO FAR TO HAVE THAT
TURN BACK NOW, AND INDEED, HE
SAID WOMEN SHOULD BE PUNISHED,
THAT THERE SHOULD BE SOME FORM
OF PUNISHMENT FOR WOMEN WHO
OBTAIN ABORTIONS, AND I COULD
JUST NOT BE MORE OPPOSED TO THAT
KIND OF THINKING.
MR. WALLACE: I WILL GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO RESPOND, BUT I WANT TO
EXPLORE HOW FAR YOU BELIEVE THE
RIGHT TO ABORTION GOES.
YOU HAVE BEEN QUOTED AS SAYING
THAT THE FETUS HAS NO
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
YOU ALSO VOTED AGAINST A BAN ON
LATE-TERM PARTIAL-BIRTH
ABORTIONS, WHY?
MR. TRUMP: BECAUSE
MRS. CLINTON: BECAUSE ROE VERSUS
WADE SETS OUT THAT THERE CAN BE
REGULATIONS ON ABORTION SO AS
LONG AS THE LIFE OF THE HEALTH
AND MOTHER ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT.
WHEN I VOTED AS A SENATOR, I DID
NOT THINK THAT WAS THE CASE.
THAT KIND OF CASES THAT FALL AT
THE END OF PREGNANCY ARE OFTEN
THE MOST HEARTBREAKING, PAINFUL
DECISIONS FOR FAMILIES TO MAKE.
I HAVE MET WITH WOMEN WHO HAVE
TOWARDS THE END OF THEIR
PREGNANCY GET THE WORST NEWS ONE
CAN GET, THAT THEIR HEALTH IS IN
JEOPARDY IF THEY CONTINUE TO
CARRY TO TERM OR THAT SOMETHING
TERRIBLE HAS HAPPENED OR JUST
BEEN DISCOVERED ABOUT THE
PREGNANCY.
I DO NOT THINK THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE STEPPING IN
AND MAKING THOSE MOST PERSONAL
OF DECISIONS, SO YOU CAN
REGULATE IF YOU ARE DOING SO
WITH THE LIFE AND HEALTH OF THE
MOTHER TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP, YOUR
REACTION, TICK DOWN THIS ISSUE
OF LATE-TERM PARTIAL ABORTION.
MR. TRUMP: I THINK IT IS
TERRIBLE.
IF YOU GO WITH WHAT HILLARY IS
SAYING IT, YOU CAN RIP THE BABY
OUT OF THE WO OF THE MOTHERMB --
WOMB OF THE MOTHER JUST PRIOR TO
THE BIRTH OF THE BABY.
THAT IS NOT OK TO ME.
BASED ON WHERE SHE IS GOING, YOU
CAN TAKE THE BABY AND RIPPED THE
BABY OUT OF THE WOMB IN THE
NINTH MONTH ON THE FINAL DAY,
AND THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
MRS. CLINTON: THAT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN THESE CASES.
USING THAT TYPE OF SCARE
RHETORIC IS TERRIBLY
UNFORTUNATE.
YOU SHOULD MEET SOME OF THE
WOMEN I HAVE MET WITH, WOMEN WHO
I HAVE KNOWN OVER THE COURSE OF
MY LIFE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE WORST
POSSIBLE CHOICES THAT ANY WOMAN
AND HER FAMILY HAS TO MAKE, AND
I DO NOT BELIEVE THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE MAKING IT.
I HAD THE GREAT HONOR OF
TRAVELING ACROSS THE WORLD ON
BEHALF OF OUR COUNTRY.
I HAVE BEEN TO COUNTRIES WHERE
GOVERNMENTS HAVE FORCED WOMEN TO
HAVE ABORTIONS LIKE THEY USED TO
DO IN CHINA OR FORCE WOMEN TO
BARE CHILDREN LIKE THEY USED TO
DO IN ROMANIA, AND I CONTINUE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS NO
BUSINESS IN THAT DECISION THAT
WOMEN MAKE WITH THEIR FAMILIES
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR FAITH,
WITH MEDICAL ADVICE, AND I WILL
STAND UP FOR THAT RIGHT.
MR. WALLACE: JUST BRIEFLY, I
WANT TO MOVE ON.
MR. TRUMP: NOBODY HAS BUSINESS
DOING WHAT I JUST SAID, DOING
THAT AS LATE AS 1, 2, 3, OR FOUR
DAYS PRIOR TO BIRTH, NOBODY HAS
THAT RIGHT.
MR. WALLACE: LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE SUBJECT OF IMMIGRATION.
THERE IS A MUST KNOW ISSUE THAT
SEPARATES THE TWO OF YOU MORE
THAN IMMIGRATION, ACTUALLY THERE
ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
SEPARATE THE TWO OF YOU.
MR. TRUMP, YOU WANT TO BUILD A
WALL.
SECRETARY CLINTON, YOU HAVE
OFFERED NO SPECIFIC PLAN ON HOW
YOU WANT TO SECURE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
MR. TRUMP, YOU ARE CALLING FOR
MAJOR DEPORTATIONS.
SECRETARY CLINTON, YOU SAY YOU
WILL OFFER A PACKAGE WITHIN THE
FIRST HUNDRED DAYS THAT INCLUDES
A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP.
THE QUESTION IS WHY ARE YOU
RIGHT AND YOUR OPPONENT WRONG.
ESTHER TRUMP, YOU GO FIRST.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
MRS. CLINTON: YOU WANT TO GIVE
MR. TRUMP: WE NEED STRONG
BORDERS.
WE HAVE FOUR MOTHERS IN THE
AUDIENCE TONIGHT, UNBELIEVABLE
PEOPLE I HAVE GOTTEN TO KNOW
WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
BRUTALLY KILLED BY PEOPLE THAT
CAME INTO THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
YOU HAVE THOUSANDS OF MOTHERS
AND FATHERS AND RELATIVES ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE COMING IN ILLEGALLY.
DRUGS ARE POURING IN THROUGH THE
BORDER.
WE HAVE NO COUNTRY IF WE HAVE NO
EVERY ONCE TO GIVE AMNESTY AND
HAVE OPEN BORDERS.
AS YOU KNOW, THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS, 16,500 PLUS ICE LAST
WEEK ENDORSED ME, FIRST AND THEY
HAVE EVER ENDORSED A CANDIDATE.
IT MEANS THEIR JOB IS TOUGHER,
BUT THEY KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
THEY KNEW IT BETTER THAN
ANYBODY.
THEY WANT STRONG BORDERS.
A FEW WE HAVE TO HAVE STRONG
BORDERS.
I WAS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE THE OTHER
DAY, THE BIGGEST COMPLAINT THEY
HAVE WITH ALL THE PROBLEMS GOING
ON IN THE WORLD, MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS CAUSED BY HILLARY
CLINTON AND BARACK OBAMA, ALL OF
THE PROBLEMS, THE SINGLE BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS HEROIN THAT POURS
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDERS,
JUST POURING AND DESTROYING
THEIR YOUTH, POISONING THE BLOOD
OF THE YOUTH AND PLENTY OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE STRONG BORDERS.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THE DRUGS OUT OF
OUR COUNTRY.
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE GETTING THE
DRUGS, THEY ARE GETTING THE
CASH.
WE NEED STRONG BORDERS.
WE NEED ABSOLUTE, WE CANNOT GIVE
AMNESTY, NOW, I WANT TO BUILD A
WALL, WE NEED THE WALL.
THE BORDER PATROL, ICE, THEY ALL
WANT THE WALL.
WE STOP IN DROVES.
WE SURE UP THE BORDER.
ONE OF MY FIRST ASKED WILL BE TO
GET ALL OF THE DRUGLORDS, THE
BAD ONES.
WE HAVE SOME BAD, BAD PEOPLE AND
IS THIS -- IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
HAVE TO GO OUT.
WE WILL GET THEM OUT, SECURE THE
BORDER, AND AT A LATER DATE WE
WILL MAKE A DETERMINATION AS TO
THE REST, BUT WE HAVE SOME BAD
HOMBRES HERE AND WE HAVE TO GET
THEM OUT.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON,
THE SAME QUESTIONS YOU.
MRS. CLINTON: I WAS THINKING
ABOUT A YOUNG GIRL I MET IN LAS
VEGAS, CARLA, WHO WAS WORRIED
HER PARENTS MIGHT BE DEPORTED
BECAUSE SHE WAS BORN IN THIS
COUNTRY, BUT THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WORK HARD AND DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO GIVE HER A GOOD
LIFE, AND YOU'RE RIGHT, I DON'T
WANT TO RIP FAMILIES APART.
I DON'T WANT TO BE SENDING
PARENTS AWAY FROM CHILDREN.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
DEPORTATION FORCE THAT DONALD
HAS TALKED ABOUT IN ACTION IN
OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE 11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE 4 MILLION AMERICAN
CITIZEN CHILDREN.
15 MILLION PEOPLE.
HE SAID AS RECENTLY AS A FEW
WEEKS AGO IN PHOENIX THAT EVERY
UNDOCUMENTED PERSON WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION.
NOW HERE IS WHAT THAT MEANS.
IT MEANS YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
A MASSIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRESENCE, WHERE LAW-ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WOULD BE GOING SCHOOL
TO SCHOOL, HOME TO HOME,
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS, ROUNDING
UP PEOPLE UNDOCUMENTED, THEN WE
WOULD HAVE TO PUT THEM ON TRAINS
AND BUSES TO GET THEM OUT OF OUR
COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT IS IN AN IDEA NOT
IN KEEPING WITH WHO WE ARE AS A
NATION.
I THINK IT IS AN IDEA THAT WOULD
READ OUR COUNTRY APART.
I HAVE BEEN FOR BORDER SECURITY
FOR YEARS.
I'VE VOTED FOR BORDER SECURITY
AND THE UNITED STATES SENATE,
AND MY COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
PLAN INCLUDES BORDER SECURITY,
BUT I WANT TO PUT OUR RESOURCES
WHERE THEY ARE MOST NEEDED,
GETTING RID OF ANY VIOLENT
PERSON, ANYBODY WHO SHOULD BE
DEPORTED, WE SHOULD DEPORT THEM.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE WALL THAT
DONALD TALKS ABOUT BUILDING.
HE WENT TO MEXICO AND HAD A
MEETING WITH THE MEXICAN
PRESIDENT, DIDN'T EVEN RAISE IT.
HE CHOKED.
SO I THINK WE ARE BOTH IN
IMMIGRATION -- NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS AND A NATION OF LAWS,
AND THAT WE CAN ACT ACCORDINGLY,
AND THAT'S WHY I'M INTRODUCING
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
AND A PATH TO CITIZENSHIP.
MR. WALLACE: THANK YOU,
SECRETARY CLINTON.
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP --
MR. TRUMP: FIRST OF ALL, I HAD A
GOOD MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF MEXICO, VERY NICE MAN.
WE WILL BE DOING VERY MUCH
BETTER WITH MEXICO ON TRADE
DEALS, THE NAFTA DEALS WAS ONE
OF THE WORST DEAL SIGNED BY
ANYBODY.
IT IS A DISASTER.
HILLARY CLINTON FOUGHT FOR THE
WALL.
IN 2006 OR THEREABOUTS.
NOW, SHE NEVER GETS ANYTHING
DONE, SO NATURALLY THE WALL WAS
NOT BUILT, BUT HILLARY CLINTON
WANTED THE WALL.
MR. WALLACE: SIR, LET ME ASK
THIS
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
SECRETARY CLINTON.
MRS. CLINTON: I VOTED FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
MR. TRUMP: AND THE WALL.
MRS. CLINTON: THERE WERE SOME
LIMITED PLACES WHERE THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE.
THERE IS ALSO NECESSARILY GOING
TO BE NEW TECHNOLOGY AND HOW TO
DEPLOY THAT, BUT IT IS CLEAR
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
DONALD HAS BEEN PROPOSING, HE
STARTED HIS CAMPAIGN BASHING
IMMIGRANTS CALLING THEM RACISTS,
CRIMINALS -- RAPISTS, CRIMINALS,
DRUG DEALERS.
HE HAS A IDEA ABOUT WHAT WE
SHOULD DO TO DEAL WITH
IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT I AM ARGUMENT IN -- WHAT I
AM ARGUING IS THAT BRINGING THEM
OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND PUTTING
THEM INTO THE FORMAL ECONOMY
WILL BE GOOD SO THAT EMPLOYERS
CAN'T EXPLOIT THEM AND UNDERCUT
AMERICAN WAGES, AND DONALD KNOWS
A LOT ABOUT THIS.
HE USED UNDOCUMENTED LABOR TO
BUILD TRUMP TOWER.
WHEN THEY COMPLAIN, HE BASICALLY
SAID WHAT A LOT OF EMPLOYERS DO,
YOU COMPLAIN, I WILL GET YOU
DEPORTED.
I WANT TO GET EVERYBODY OUT OF
THE SHADOWS, GET THE ECONOMY
WORKING, AND NOT LET EMPLOYERS
LIKE DONALD EXPLOIT UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS, WHICH HURTS AMERICAN
WORKERS.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP?
MR. TRUMP: PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS
MOVED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OUT.
THEY HAVE BEEN DEPORTED.
SHE DOES NOT WANT TO SAY THAT,
BUT THAT IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED,
AND THAT IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED
BIG LEAGUE.
AS FAR AS MOVING THESE PEOPLE
ALLOW, WE EITHER HAVE A COUNTRY
OR DON'T.
WE ARE A COUNTRY OF LAWS.
WE EITHER HAVE A BORDER OR
DON'T.
YOU CAN COME BACK IN AND BECOME
A CITIZEN, BUT IS VERY UNFAIR.
WE HAD MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
DID THE RIGHT WAY, ONLINE,
WAITING.
WE ARE GOING TO SPEED UP THE
PROCESS, VAGUELY, BECAUSE IT IS
AN EFFICIENT.
IT IS VERY UNFAIR THAT SOMEONE
RUNS ACROSS THE BORDER, BECOMES
A CITIZEN -- UNDER HER PLAN, YOU
WOULD HAVE OPEN BORDERS, I
DISASTER ON TRADE AND A DISASTER
WITH OPEN BORDERS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS DEPORTED
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
MR. TRUMP: WE WILL
MRS. CLINTON: WE WILL NOT HAVE
OPEN BORDERS.
WE WILL HAVE SECURE BORDERS, BUT
WE WILL ALSO HAVE REFORM.
THIS USED TO BE A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE.
MR. WALLACE: EXCUSE ME --
MRS. CLINTON: AND GEORGE W. BUSH
SUPPORTED IT AS WELL.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON,
I WANT TO CLEAR UP YOUR POSITION
ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IN A
SPEECH YOU GAVE TO A BRAZILIAN
BANK FOR WHICH YOU WERE PAID
$225,000, WE HAVE LEARNED FROM
WIKILEAKS THAT YOU SAID THIS,
"MY DREAM IS A HIS --
HEMISPHERIC OPEN MARKET WITH
OPEN TRADE AND OPEN BORDERS."
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
PLEASE QUIET EVERYBODY.
IS THAT YOUR DREAM, OPEN
BORDERS?
MRS. CLINTON: IF YOU READ THE
REST OF THE SENTENCE, I WAS
TALKING ABOUT ENERGY.
WE TRADE MORE ENERGY WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS AND WE TRADE WITH THE
REST OF THE WORLD COMBINED, AND
I DO WANT US TO HAVE AN ELECTRIC
GRID, AND ENERGY SYSTEM THAT
CROSSES BORDERS, I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT BENEFIT TO US,
BUT YOU ARE VERY CLEARLY QUOTING
FROM WIKILEAKS, AND WHAT IS
IMPORTANT ABOUT WIKILEAKS IS
THAT THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT HAS
ENGAGED IN ESPIONAGE AGAINST
AMERICANS.
THEY HAVE HACKED AMERICAN
WEBSITES, AMERICAN ACCOUNTS OF
PRIVATE PEOPLE OF INSTITUTIONS,
THEN THEY HAVE GIVEN THAT
INFORMATION TO WIKILEAKS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PUTTING IT ON THE
INTERNET.
THIS HAS COME FROM THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, CLEARLY FROM
PRINTING HIMSELF.
AS OUR INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
HAVE CONFIRMED, TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTION, SO THE MOST IMPORTANT
QUESTION OF THIS EVENING IS
FINALLY WILL DONALD TRUMP ADMIT
AND CONDEMN WHAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE DOING -- THAT THE RUSSIANS
ARE DOING THIS, AND MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT HE WILL NOT HAVE THE
HELP OF PUTIN IN THIS ELECTION,
THAT HE REJECTS RUSSIAN
ESPIONAGE AGAINST AMERICANS,
WHICH HE ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED IN
THE PAST.
THOSE OF THE QUESTIONS WE NEED
ANSWERED.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD ANYTHING LIKE
THIS HAPPEN IN OUR ELECTIONS
BEFORE.
MR. TRUMP:
SHE ONCE OPEN BORDERSE
WILL POUR INTO OUR COUNTRY FROM
SYRIA.
SHE WANTS 550% MORE PEOPLE THEN
BARACK OBAMA.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, WE WILL
STOP RADICAL ISLAMIC TERRORISM
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SHE WILL NOT EVEN MENTION THE
WORDS, AND NEITHER WILL
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT SHE WANTS OPEN BORDERS, NOW
WE CAN TALK ABOUT PUTIN.
HE SAID NICE THINGS ABOUT ME, IF
WE GOT ALONG THE GOOD, THAT
WOULD BE GREAT.
IF RUSSIA AND THE UNITED STATES
GOT ALONG WELL AND WHEN AFTER
ISIS, THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
HE HAS NO RESPECT FOR HER OR OUR
PRESIDENT.
AND I WILL TELL YOU WHAT, WE ARE
IN SERIOUS TROUBLE BECAUSE WE
HAVE A COUNTRY WITH TREMENDOUS
NUMBERS OF NUCLEAR WARHEADS,
1800, BY THE WAY.
1800 NUCLEAR WARHEADS, AND SHE
IS PLAYING CHICKEN.
EVERYTHING I SEE HAS NO RESPECT
FOR THIS PERSON.
MRS. CLINTON: THAT IS BECAUSE HE
WOULD RATHER HAVE A PUPPET AS
PRESIDENT.
IT IS PRETTY CLEAR.
MR. TRUMP: YOU ARE THE TOPIC.
MRS. CLINTON: IT IS CLEAR RUSSIA
HAS ENGAGED IN CYBER ATTACKS
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES AND
YOU ENCOURAGE ESPIONAGE AGAINST
OUR PEOPLE, THAT YOU ARE WILLING
TO ESPOUSE THE PUTIN LINE, SIGN
UP FOR HIS WISH LIST, BREAK UP
NATO AND WHATEVER HE WANTS TO
DO.
AND, THAT YOU CONTINUE TO GET
HELP FROM HIM BECAUSE HE HAS A
VERY CLEAR FAVORITE IN THIS
RACE.
I THINK THIS IS SUCH AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT TRYING TO INTERFERE
IN OUR ELECTION.
WE HAVE 17 INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES, CIVILIANS AND
MILITARY, WHO HAVE ALL CONCLUDED
THAT THESE ESPIONAGE ATTACKS AND
A CYBER ATTACKS COME FROM THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE KREMLIN
AND THEY ARE DESIGNED TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS.
I FIND THAT DEEPLY DISTURBING
AND I THINK IT IS TIME.
MR. TRUMP: WHETHER IT IS RUSSIA,
CHINA, OR ANYBODY ELSE, SHE HAS
NO IDEA.
MRS. CLINTON: 17 MILITARY AND
CIVILIAN AGENCIES.
HE WOULD RATHER BELIEVE VLADIMIR
PUTIN IN THE MILITARY AND
CIVILIAN INTELLIGENCE
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE SWORN TO
PROTECT US.
I FIND THAT ABSOLUTELY
FRIGHTENING.
MR. TRUMP: SHE DOES NOT LIKE
CLINTON BECAUSE HE HAS
OUTSMARTED HER EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
EXCUSE ME, PUTIN HAS OUTSMARTED
HER IN SYRIA AND EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
MR. WALLACE: I DO NEED TO ASK
SOME QUESTIONS AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK YOU THIS DIRECT QUESTION.
THE TOP NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS OF THIS COUNTRY DO
BELIEVE RUSSIA HAS BEEN BELOW --
BEHIND THESE HACKS.
EVEN IF YOU DO NOT KNOW FOR
SURE, DO YOU CONDEMN ANY
INTERFERENCE BY RUSSIA IN THE
AMERICAN ELECTION?
MR. TRUMP: BY RUSSIA OR ANYBODY
ELSE.
MR. WALLACE: DO YOU CONDEMN?
MR. TRUMP: OF COURSE I CONDEMN.
I DO NOT KNOW PUTIN.
THIS IS NOT MY BEST FRIEND.
BUT IF THE RUSH -- UNITED STATES
GOT ALONG WITH RUSSIA, IT WOULD
NOT BE SO BAD.
BUT HE HAS OUTSMARTED HER AND
OBAMA EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
WHETHER IT IS SYRIA OR MISSILES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE START OF A
SIGNED.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE SAID,
ACCORDING TO MANY REPORTS, I
CANNOT BELIEVE THEY ALLOW US TO
DO THIS.
THEY CREATE WARHEADS AND WE
CANNOT.
THE RUSSIANS CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
SHE HAS BEEN A SMARTED BY PUTIN.
JUST LOOK AT THE MIDDLE EAST,
THEY TOOK OVER.
WE SPEND A $6 TRILLION AND THEY
TOOK OVER THE MIDDLE EAST.
SHE HAS BEEN OUTSMARTED AND
OUTPLAYED WORSE THAN ANYONE I
HAVE EVER SEEN IN ANY GOVERNMENT
WHATSOEVER.
MR. WALLACE: A $6 TRILLION AND Y
TOOK OVER THE MIDDLE EAST.
WE ARE A LONG WAY
AWAY FROM IMMIGRATION BUT I WILL
LET YOU FINISH THIS IN ABOUT 45
SECONDS.
MR. TRUMP: AND SHE ALWAYS WILL
BE.
MRS. CLINTON: I FIND IT IRONIC
HE IS RAISING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THIS IS A PERSON WHO HAS BEEN
VERY CAVALIER AND CASUAL ABOUT
THE USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
HE AS ADVOCATED MORE COUNTRIES
GETTING THEM, JAPAN, KOREA, EVEN
SAUDI ARABIA.
HE SAYS IF WE HAVE THEM, WHY
DON'T WE USE THEM, WHICH I THINK
IS TERRIFYING.
THE BOTTOM LINE ON NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IS, THAT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT GIVES THE ORDER, IT
MUST BE FOLLOWED.
THERE ARE ABOUT FOUR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE ORDER BEING GIVEN
AND THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
LAUNCHING NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO DO
SO.
THAT IS WHY 10 PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THAT AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY HAVE
COME OUT IN AN UNPRECEDENTED WAY
THAT THEY WOULD NOT TRUST DONALD
TRUMP WITH THE NUCLEAR CODES OR
TO HAVE HIS FINGER ON THE
NUCLEAR BUTTON.
MR. TRUMP: I HAVE 200 GENERALS
AND ADMIRALS, 21 ENDORSING ME,
21 CONGRESSIONAL MEDAL OF HONOR
RECIPIENTS.
AS FAR AS JAPAN AND OTHER
COUNTRIES, WE ARE BEING RIPPED
OFF BY EVERYONE IN THE WORLD.
WE ARE SPENDING A FORTUNE DOING
IT.
THEY HAVE THE BARGAIN OF A
CENTURY.
ALL I SAID IS THAT WE HAVE TO
RENEGOTIATE AGREEMENTS BECAUSE
OUR COUNTRY CANNOT AFFORD TO
DEFEND A SAUDI ARABIA, GERMANY,
SOUTH KOREA, AND MANY OTHER
PLACES.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO AFFORD IT.
SHE TOOK THAT TO ME NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
OUTLOOK, SHE HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
BE A LIAR IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER LIE.
MRS. CLINTON: I AM JUST QUOTING
YOU.
MR. TRUMP: YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
FIND THE QUOTE FOR ME.
MRS. CLINTON: NUCLEAR
COMPETITION IN ASIA, YOU SAID GO
AHEAD, ENJOY YOURSELF, FOLKS.
MR. TRUMP: AND DEFEND
YOURSELVES.
I DID NOT SAY NUCLEAR -- AND
DEFEND YOURSELF.
MRS. CLINTON: THE UNITED STATES
HAS KEPT PEACE THROUGH OUR
ALLIANCES.
DONALD WANTS TO TERRA POWER
I THINK IT MAKES THE WORLD SAFER
AND THE UNITED STATES SAFER.
I WOULD WORK WITH OUR ALLIES IN
ASIA, EUROPE, THE MIDDLE EAST,
AND ELSEWHERE.
THAT IS ONLY WAY WE WILL KEEP
THE PEACE.
MR. WALLACE: WE WILL MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT TOPIC, WHICH IS THE
ECONOMY.
I HOPE WE HANDLE THAT AS WELL AS
WE DID IMMIGRATION.
YOU ALSO HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
IDEAS ON HOW TO GET THE ECONOMY
GOING.
SECRETARY CLINTON, IN YOUR PLAN,
GOVERNMENT PLAYS A BIG ROLE.
YOU SEE MORE GOVERNMENT
SPENDING, MORE ENTITLEMENTS,
MORE TAX CREDITS AND MORE TAX
PENALTIES.
MR. TRUMP, YOU WANT TO GET
GOVERNMENT OUT OF WITH LESS
TAXES AND REGULATIONS.
WE WILL JOLT DOWN INTO THIS A
LITTLE MORE.
IN THIS OVERVIEW, EXPLAINED TO
ME WHY YOUR PLAN WILL CREATE
MORE JOBS AND GROWTH FOR THE
COUNTRY AND YOUR OPPONENTS PLAN
WILL NOT.
IN THIS ROUND, YOU GO FIRST
SECRETARY CLINTON.
MRS. CLINTON: I THINK WHEN THE
MIDDLE CLASS THRIVES, AMERICA
THRIVES.
MY PLAN IS BASED ON GROWING THE
ECONOMY, GIVING MIDDLE-CLASS
FAMILIES MANY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE BIGGEST JOBS PROGRAM IS
SINCE WORLD WAR II, JOBS WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO ADVANCE
MANUFACTURING.
I THINK WE CAN COMPETE WITH HIGH
WAGE COUNTRIES AND I THINK WE
SHOULD.
NEW JOBS AND ENERGY TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CREATE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES AND BUSINESSES.
I WANT TO DO MORE TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESS, THAT IS WHERE TWO
THIRDS OF NEW JOBS WILL COME
FROM.
I WANT TO RAISE THE NATIONAL
MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN POVERTY AND WORK FULL
TIME NOT STILL BE IN POVERTY.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WOMEN GET
EQUAL PAY FOR THE WORK WE DO.
I FEEL STRONGLY THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE AN EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT
STARTS WITH PRESCHOOL AND GOES
THROUGH COLLEGE.
THAT IS WHY I WANT MORE
TECHNICAL EDUCATION IN HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
REAL APPRENTICESHIPS TO PREPARE
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR THE JOBS OF THE
FUTURE.
I WANT TO MAKE COLLEGE
DEBT-FREE, AND FOR FAMILIES
MAKING LESS THAN $25,000, YOU
WILL NOT GET A TUITION BILL FOR
A COLLEGE IN THE PLAN I WORKED
ON WITH BERNIE SANDERS, IF IT IS
ENACTED.
WE WILL WORK HARD TO MAKE SURE
IT IS BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO GO
WHERE THE MONEY IS.
MOST OF THE GAINS IN THE LAST
YEAR SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION
HAD GONE TO THE VERY TOP.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE WEALTHY
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
WE WILL HAVE CORPORATIONS MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION GROUP -- GREATER
THAN THEY ARE NOW.
THAT HAS BEEN ANALYZED BY
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS AND THEY SAY
IT COULD PRODUCE 10 MILLION NEW
JOBS.
BY CONTRAST, DONALD PLAN HAS
BEEN ANALYZED TO CONCLUDE IT
MIGHT LOSE 3.5 MILLION JOBS
BECAUSE HIS WHOLE PLAN IS TO CUT
TAXES AND GIVE THE BIGGEST TAX
BREAKS EVER TO THE WEALTHY AND
CORPORATIONS.
ADDING $20 TRILLION TO OUR DECK,
AND CAUSING THE KIND OF
DISLOCATION WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE
BECAUSE IT TRULY WILL BE
TRICKLE-DOWN ECONOMICS ON
STEROIDS.
THE PLAN I HAVE WILL ACTUALLY
PRODUCE GREATER OPPORTUNITY.
THE PLAN HE HAS WILL COST US
JOBS AND POSSIBLY LEAD TO
ANOTHER GREAT RECESSION.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY, THANK
YOU.
MR. TRUMP, WHY WILL YOUR PLAN
CREATE MORE JOBS AND GROWTH?
MR. TRUMP: HER PLAN WILL RAISE
TAXES, EVEN DOUBLE YOUR TAXES.
IT IS A DISASTER.
SHE CAN SAY ALL SHE WANTS ABOUT
COLLEGE GROWTH?
MR. TRUMP: TUITION, I AM A BIG
PROPONENT.
WE WILL DO A LOT OF THINGS FOR
COLLEGE TUITION.
BUT THE REST OF THE PUBLIC WILL
BE PAYING FOR IT.
WE WILL HAVE A MASSIVE, MASSIVE
TAX INCREASE UNDER HILLARY
CLINTON'S PLAN.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO PICK OFF
WHERE WE LEFT.
WHEN I SAID JAPAN AND GERMANY,
NOT TO SINGLE THEM OUT, THESE
ARE VERY RICH AND POWERFUL
COUNTRIES.
SAUDI ARABIA, NOTHING BUT MONEY.
YET WE PROTECT SAUDI ARABIA.
WHY ARE THEY PAYING?
I QUESTIONED NATO, WHY ARE THEY
PAYING?
SINCE I DID THIS A YEAR AGO, ALL
OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE PAYING.
I HAVE BEEN GIVEN A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR IT.
THEY HAVE TO PAY UP.
WE ARE PROTECTING PEOPLE, THEY
HAVE TO PAY UP.
I AM A BIG FAN OF NATO BUT THEY
HAVE TO PAY UP TO READ SHE SAYS
WE LOVE OUR ALLIES AND THINK
THEY ARE GREAT.
IT IS HARD TO GET THEM TO PAY UP
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY SAYING WE
THINK HOW GREAT THEY ARE.
WE HAVE TO TELL JAPAN IN A VERY
NICE WAY AND GERMANY, SOUTH
KOREA, YOU HAVE TO HELP US OUT.
DURING HIS REGIME, PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S REGIME, WE DOUBLED OUR
NATIONAL DEBT.
WE ARE UP TO $20 TRILLION.
MY PLAN, WE WILL NEGOTIATE
TRADE.
WE WILL HAVE MORE FREE TRADE
THEN WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE HORRIBLE DEALS.
OUR JOBS ARE TAKEN BY NAFTA, THE
BILL HER HUSBAND SIGNED.
JOBS ARE BEING SUCKED OUT OF OUR
ECONOMY.
YOU GO TO PENNSYLVANIA, OHIO,
FLORIDA, AND OF THEM, UPSTATE
NEW YORK, OUR JOBS HAVE FLED TO
MEXICO AND OTHER PLACES.
I AM GOING TO RENEGOTIATE NAFTA.
IF I CANNOT MAKE A GREAT DEAL,
THEN WE WILL TERMINATE NAFTA AND
CREATE NEW DEALS.
WE WILL TERMINATED AND MAKE A
GREAT TRADE DEAL.
IF WE CANNOT, WE WILL GO OUR
SEPARATE WAYS BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN A DISASTER.
WE WILL CUT TAXES MASSIVELY AND
BUSINESS TAXES.
THEY WILL START HIRING PEOPLE
AND WE WILL BRING THE $2.5
TRILLION OFFSHORE BACK INTO THE
COUNTRY.
WE WILL START THE ENGINE ROLLING
AGAIN BECAUSE RIGHT NOW OUR
COUNTRY IS DYING AT 1% GDP.
MRS. CLINTON: LET ME TRANSLATE
THAT IF I CAN, CHRIS.
MR. TRUMP: YOU CANNOT.
MRS. CLINTON: HE WILL ADVOCATE
FOR THE LARGEST TAX THAT WE HAVE
SEEN, THREE TIMES MORE THAN THE
TAX CUTS UNDER THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE SAID REPEATEDLY
THROUGHOUT THIS CAMPAIGN, I WILL
NOT RAISE TAXES ON ANYONE MAKING
GEORGIA $50,000 OR LESS.
I ALSO WILL NOT ADD A PENNY TO
THE DEBT.
I HAVE COSTED OUT WHAT I WILL
DO.
HE WILL, THROUGH HIS MASSIVE TAX
CUTS, ADD $20 TRILLION TO THE
DEBT.
HE MENTIONED THE DEBT.
WE KNOW HOW TO GET CONTROL OF
THE DEBT.
WHEN MY HUSBAND WAS PRESIDENT,
WE HAD A SURPLUS AND WERE ON THE
PATH TO ELIMINATING THE NATIONAL
DEBT.
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA CAME INTO
OFFICE, HE INHERITED THE WORST
ECONOMIC DISASTER SINCE THE
GREAT DEPRESSION.
HE CUT THE DEFICIT BY TWO
THIRDS.
YES, ONE WAY YOU GO AFTER DEBT
AND CREATE JOBS IS BY INVESTING
IN PEOPLE.
SO I DO HAVE INVESTMENTS IN NEW
JOBS AND EDUCATION, SKILL
TRAINING, AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO GET AHEAD AND STAY
AHEAD.
THIS IS THE KIND OF APPROACH
THAT WILL WORK.
CUTTING TAXES ON THE WEALTHY --
WE HAVE TRIED THAT.
BUT IT HAS NOT WORKED THE WAY
THEY THINK.
MR. WALLACE: I WANT TO PURSUE
YOUR PLAN.
IN MANY WAYS, IT IS SIMILAR TO
THE OBAMA STIMULUS LAN IN 2009.
THAT HAS LED TO THE SLOWEST GDP
GROWTH SINCE 1949.
MR. TRUMP: CORRECT.
MR. WALLACE: THANK YOU, SIR.
YOU TOLD ME IN JULY WHEN WE
SPOKE THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA DID
NOT GET TO DO ENOUGH IN WHAT HE
WAS TRYING TO DO.
IF YOUR PLAN BASICALLY EVEN MORE
OF THE OBAMA STIMULUS?
MRS. CLINTON: IT IS A
COMBINATION, CHRIS.
LET ME SAY, WHEN YOU INHERIT THE
LEVEL OF ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA INHERITED,
IT WAS A REAL TOUCH AND GO
SITUATION.
I WAS IN THE SENATE BEFORE I
BECAME SECRETARY OF EIGHT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN PEOPLE AS
PHYSICALLY DISTRAUGHT AS THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION TEAM WAS
BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO
THE ECONOMY.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT THE
STEPS PRESIDENT OBAMA TOOK SAVED
THE ECONOMY.
HE DOES NOT GET THE CREDIT HE
DESERVES FOR TAKING SOME VERY
HARD POSITIONS.
BUT IT WAS A TERRIBLE RECESSION.
NOW WE DUG OURSELVES OUT OF IT.
WE ARE STANDING, BUT NOT YET
RUNNING.
WHAT I AM PROPOSING, IS THAT WE
INVEST IN THE GROUND UP.
NOT THE TOP DOWN.
THAT WILL NOT WORK.
THAT IS WHY I HAVE PUT FORWARD
TO NOT ADD A PENNY TO THE DEBT.
IT IS THE KIND OF APPROACH THAT
WILL ENABLE MORE PEOPLE TO TAKE
THOSE NEW JOBS, HIGHER PAYING
JOBS.
WE ARE BEGINNING TO SEE
INCREASES IN INCOME AND WE HAVE
HAD A LONG STRING OF INCREASING
JOBS.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE TO GET THE
WHOLE ECONOMY MOVING.
THAT IS WHAT I BELIEVE I WILL BE
ABLE TO DO.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP, EVEN
CONSERVATIVE ECONOMISTS WHO LOOK
AT YOUR PLAN SAY THE NUMBERS DO
NOT ADD UP.
YOUR IDEA, YOU TALKED ABOUT 25
MILLION JOBS CREATED, 4% OVER A
10 YEAR PERIOD IS UNREALISTIC.
AND THEY SAY WITH OIL PRICES AS
LOW AS THEY ARE RIGHT NOW, THAT
IS UNREALISTIC, AS WELL.
MR. TRUMP: I JUST LEFT SOME HIGH
REPRESENTATIVES, THEY ARE
GROWING AT 8%.
CHINA IS GROWING AT 7%, AND A
CATASTROPHICALLY LOW NUMBER.
WE ARE GROWING, OUR LAST REPORT
RIGHT AROUND THE 1% LEVEL AND I
THINK IT IS GOING DOWN.
AT THE END OF LAST WEEK, THEY
CAME OUT WITH AN ANEMIC JOBS
REPORT, A TERRIBLE JOBS REPORT.
I SAID, IS THAT THE LAST JOBS
REPORT FOR THE ELECTION?
IF SO, I SHOULD WIN EASILY.
THE REPORT WAS SO BAD, IT WAS SO
BAD.
OUR ECONOMY IS STARTING, WE HAVE
LOST JOBS AND BUSINESSES.
WE ARE NOT MAKING THINGS
ANYMORE, RELATIVELY SPEAKING.
PRODUCTS ARE POURING IN FROM
CHINA AND VIETNAM AND ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
I VISITED SO MANY COMMUNITIES,
THIS IS SUCH AN INCREDIBLE
EDUCATION FOR ME, CHRIS.
I HAVE DEVELOPED SO MANY FRIENDS
OVER THE LAST YEAR.
AND THEY CRY WHEN THEY SEE WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
I PASSED FACTORIES THAT WERE
THRIVING 25 YEARS AGO, BECAUSE
OF THE BILL HER HUSBAND PASSED
AND SHE BLESSED.
SHE COULD SAY HER HUSBAND DID
WELL, BUT BOY DID THEY SUFFER
WHEN NAFTA KICKED IN.
IT KICKED IN AFTER THEY LEFT.
BOY, DID THEY SUFFER.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE WORST THING
EVER SIGNED BY OUR COUNTRY.
NOW SHE WANTS TO SIGN THE
TRANSPACIFIC PARTNERSHIP.
SHE LIED WHEN SHE DID NOT
COLLECT THE GOLD STANDARD.
SHE TOTALLY LIVE, SHE DID CALL
IT THE GOLD STANDARD.
A FACT CHECKED AND SHOW THAT I
WAS RIGHT.
MR. WALLACE: I WANT TO GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO BRIEFLY SPEAK TO
THAT.
GO AHEAD.
BRIEFLY.
MRS. CLINTON: NUMBER ONE, WHEN I
SAW THE AGREEMENT FOR TPP I
THOUGHT I WAS AGAINST IT, I HAD
THE SAME TEST IS THAT IT NEEDS
TO INCREASE JOBS, INCOME, AND
NATIONAL SECURITY.
I WILL BE AGAINST IT WHEN I AM
PRESIDENT.
ONLY ONE OF US ON STAGE HAS
SHIFTED JOBS TO MEXICO AND THAT
IS TRUMP.
HE HAS SHIFTED JOBS TO MANY
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING MEXICO.
ONE OF OUR PROBLEMS WITH CHINA
IS THE ILLEGAL DUMPING OF STEEL
AND ALUMINUM IN OUR MARKETS.
I FIGHT AGAINST THAT AS A
SENATOR AND SECRETARY OF STATE.
DONALD HAS BOUGHT CHINESE STEEL
THE TRUMP HOTEL IN LAS VEGAS WAS
MADE IN STEEL HE GIVES A JOBS TO
CHINESE STEEL WORKERS.
WE WILL PULL THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER AND HAVE TRADE
AGREEMENTS WE ENFORCE.
THAT IS WHY I WILL HAVE A TRADE
PROSECUTOR FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY.
AND WE WILL ENFORCE THOSE
AGREEMENTS AND LOOK FOR
BUSINESSES TO BUY AMERICAN
PRODUCTS.
MR. TRUMP: A SIMPLE QUESTION.
SHE HAS BEEN DOING THIS FOR 30
YEARS.
WHY THE HELL DID YOU NOT DO THIS
OVER THE PAST 15, 20 YEARS.
MRS. CLINTON: EXCUSE ME.
MR. TRUMP: MY TURN.
YOU ARE INVOLVED IN MANY ASPECTS
OF THIS COUNTRY.
THE ONE THING YOU HAVE OVER ME
IS EXPERIENCE, BUT IT IS BAD
EXPERIENCE.
FOR 30 YEARS YOU HAVE BEEN IN A
POSITION TO HELP.
IF YOU SAY THAT I USED SOMETHING
ELSE, MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME
TO DO THAT, I WOULD NOT MIND.
YOU TALK, BUT YOU GET NOTHING
DONE, HILLARY.
JUST LIKE WHEN YOU RAN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, $6 BILLION WAS
MISSING.
HOW DO YOU MISS $6 BILLION?
SIX BILLION DOLLARS WAS EITHER
STOLEN -- THEY DO NOT KNOW.
IT IS GONE, $6 BILLION.
IF YOU BECOME PRESIDENT, THIS
COUNTRY WILL BE IN SOME MASS,
BELIEVE ME.
MRS. CLINTON: FIRST OF OCTOBER
WHAT HE JUST SAID ABOUT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT IS NOT ONLY
UNTRUE, IT IS BEEN DEBUNKED
NUMEROUS TIMES.
IT IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
HE RAISED THE 30 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
LET'S TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THAT.
BACK IN THE 1970'S I WORKED FOR
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND,
TAKING ON DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICAN KIDS IN
SCHOOLS.
HE WAS GETTING SUED BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN HIS APARTMENT
BUILDINGS.
IN THE 1980'S, I WAS WORKING TO
REFORM THE SCHOOLS IN ARKANSAS.
HE WAS BORROWING $14 MILLION
FROM HIS FATHER TO START HIS
BUSINESSES.
IN THE 1990'S I WENT TO BEIJING
AND SAID WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE
HUMAN RIGHTS.
HE INSULTED A FORMER MISS
UNIVERSE, CALLED ALICIA MACHADO
AND EATING MACHINE.
WHEN I MONITORED THE RAID THAT
BROUGHT OSAMA BIN LADEN TO
JUSTICE, HE WAS HOSTING
"CELEBRITY APPRENTICE."
I AM HAPPY TO COMPARE MY 30
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE, WHAT I HAVE
DONE FOR THIS COUNTRY, HELPING
EVERY WAY I COULD, ESPECIALLY
KIDS AND FAMILIES GET AHEAD,
YOU'RE 30 YEARS.
I WILL LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
MAKE THAT DECISION.
MR. TRUMP: I DID A MUCH BETTER
JOB, I BUILT A MASSIVE COMPANY
WITH MANY ASSETS, WORTH MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
I STARTED WITH A $1 MILLION LOAN
AND BUILD A PHENOMENAL COMPANY.
IF WE COULD RUN OUR COUNTRY THE
WAY I HAVE RUN MY COMPANY, WE
WOULD HAVE A COUNTRY YOU WOULD
BE SO PROUD OF, YOU WOULD EVEN
BE PROUD OF IT.
AND FRANKLY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HER REAL RECORD, TAKE A LOOK AT
SERIOUS AND THE MIGRATION, TAKE
A LOOK AT LIBYA AND IRAQ.
SHE GAVE US ISIS BECAUSE HER AND
OBAMA CREATED THIS HUGE VACUUM
AND A SMALL GROUP CAME OUT OF
THAT HUGE VACUUM BECAUSE WE
NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN IRAQ.
BUT ONCE WE WERE THERE WE SHOULD
NEVER HAVE GOTTEN OUT THE WAY
THEY WANTED TO GET OUT.
SHE GAVE US ISIS AS IT SURE IS
YOU ARE SITTING THERE.
AND NOW ISIS IS IN 32 COUNTRIES.
HOW WILL SHE GET RID OF ISIS?
SHE WILL GET RID OF NOBODY.
MR. WALLACE: WE WILL GET TO HOT
IN A FEW MOMENTS.
THE NEXT SEGMENT IS FITNESS TO
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
MR. TRUMP, AT THE LAST DEBATE,
YOU SAID YOUR TALK ABOUT
GRABBING WOMEN WAS JUST THAT,
TALK, AND THAT YOU HAD NEVER
ACTUALLY DONE IT.
SINCE THEN, NINE WOMEN HAVE COME
FORWARD AND SAID THAT YOU EITHER
GROUP TO THEM OR KISS TO THEM --
GROPED THEM OR KISSED THEM
WITHOUT THEIR CONSENT.
WHY WOULD THEY ALL MAKE UP THESE
OF STORIES?
AND SINCE THIS IS A QUESTION FOR
BOTH OF YOU, SECRETARY CLINTON,
MR. TRUMP SAYS WHAT YOUR HUSBAND
DID AND YOU DEFENDED WAS EVEN
WORSE.
MR. TRUMP, YOU GO FIRST.
MR. TRUMP: FIRST OF ALL, THOSE
OF STORIES HAVE BEEN LARGELY
DEBUNKED.
I DO NOT KNOW THOSE PEOPLE.
I HAVE A FEELING IT WAS HER
CAMPAIGN THAT DID IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT CAME OUT
TODAY, I WAS WONDERING WHAT
HAPPENED WITH MY RALLY IN
CHICAGO WHERE WE HAD SUCH
VIOLENCE.
SHE IS THE ONE, AND OBAMA, THAT
CAUSED THE VIOLENCE.
THEY HIRED PEOPLE, PAID THEM
$1500 AND THEY ARE ON TAPE
SAYING THEY CAUSED FIGHTS AND
DID BAD THINGS.
I WOULD SAY THOSE STORIES ARE
TOTALLY FALSE.
I DID NOT EVEN APOLOGIZE TO MY
WIFE, WHO IS SITTING RIGHT HERE,
BECAUSE I DID NOT DO ANYTHING.
I DID NOT KNOW ANY OF THESE
WOMEN, I DID NOT SEE THEM.
THE ONE ON THE PLANE -- I THINK
THEY WANT FAME OR HER CAMPAIGN
TO WIN.
I THINK IT IS HER CAMPAIGN.
WHEN I SAW WHAT THEY DID, A
CRIMINAL ACT, BY THE WAY,
TELLING PEOPLE TO GO OUT AND
START FISTFIGHTS AND VIOLENCE.
I TELL YOU WHAT, IN CHICAGO
PEOPLE WERE HURT AND COULD HAVE
BEEN KILLED IN THAT RIOT.
THAT IS NOW ALL ON TAPE, STARTED
BY HER.
I BELIEVE CHRIS, THAT SHE GOT
THESE PEOPLE TO STEP FORWARD.
IF IT WAS NOT, THEY GET THERE 10
MINUTES OF FAME.
BUT IT WAS ALL FICTION.
IT WAS LIES AND IT WAS FICTION.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON.
MRS. CLINTON: AT THE LAST DEBATE
WE HEARD DONALD TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HE DID TO WOMEN.
AND AFTER THAT, A NUMBER OF
WOMEN HAVE COME FORWARD SAYING
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HE DID TO
THEM.
WHAT WAS HIS RESPONSE?
HE HELD THE NUMBER OF BIG
RALLIES WHERE HE SAID THAT HE
COULD NOT POSSIBLY HAVE DONE
THOSE THINGS TO THOSE WOMEN
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT ATTRACTIVE
ENOUGH.
MR. TRUMP: I DID NOT SAY THAT.
I DID NOT SAY THAT.
MR. WALLACE: HER TWO MINUTES.
FOR TWO MINUTES.
MRS. CLINTON: HE WENT ON TO SAY,
LOOK AT HER.
I DO NOT THINK SO.
ABOUT ANOTHER WOMAN, HE SAID,
THAT WOULD NOT BE MY FIRST
CHOICE.
HE ATTACKED THE WOMAN REPORTER
WRITING THE STORY, CALLED HER
DISGUSTING, AS HE HAS CALLED A
NUMBER OF WOMEN DURING THIS
CAMPAIGN.
DONALD THINKS BELITTLING WOMEN
MAKES HIM BIGGER.
HE GOES AFTER THEIR DIGNITY,
THEIR SELF WORTH, AND I DO NOT
THINK THERE IS A WOMAN ANYWHERE
WHO DOES NOT KNOW WHAT THAT
FEELS LIKE.
WE NOW KNOW WHAT DONALD THINKS
AND WHAT HE SAYS AND HOW HE ACTS
TOWARD WOMEN.
THAT IS WHO DONALD IS.
I THINK IT IS UP TO ALL OF US TO
DEMONSTRATE WHO WE ARE.
AND WHO OUR COUNTRY IS.
AND TO STAND UP AND BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE EXPECT FROM
OUR NEXT PRESIDENT.
HOW WE WANT TO BRING OUR COUNTRY
TOGETHER, WHERE WE DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE THE KIND OF PITTING ONE
PERSON AGAINST ANOTHER.
WHERE INSTEAD WE CELEBRATE
DIVERSITY, LIFT PEOPLE UP, AND
MAKE OUR COUNTRY EVEN GREATER.
AMERICA IS GREAT BECAUSE AMERICA
IS GOOD.
AND IT REALLY IS UP TO ALL OF US
TO MAKE THAT TRUE NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE.
AND PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
MR. TRUMP: NOBODY HAS MORE
RESPECT FOR WOMEN THAN I DO.
NOBODY.
[LAUGHTER]
MR. TRUMP: FRANKLY, THOSE
STORIES HAVE BEEN LARGELY
DEBUNKED.
I REALLY WANT TO JUST TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
SHE MENTIONS THIS, WHICH IS ALL
FICTION, ALL FICTION.
PROBABLY OR POSSIBLY STARTED BY
HER AND HER VERY SLEAZY
CAMPAIGN.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHAT IS NOT
FICTION ARE HER E-MAILS WHERE
SHE DESTROYED 33,000 E-MAILS,
CRIMINAL, CRIMINALLY, AFTER
GETTING A SUBPOENA FROM THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE FBI?
I DO NOT KNOW.
WE HAVE A FOUR-STAR GENERAL
TODAY, WE READ IT AND ALL THE
PAPERS, WHO POTENTIALLY SERVED
FIVE YEARS IN JAIL FOR LYING TO
THE FBI.
ONE LINE.
-- ONE LIE.
SHE HAS LIGHT HUNDREDS OF TIMES
TO THE PEOPLE, CONGRESS, AND THE
FBI.
HE WILL PROBABLY GO TO JAIL,
THIS IS A FOUR-STAR GENERAL.
AND SHE GETS AWAY WITH IT AND
SHE CAN RUN FOR THE PRESIDENCY
OF THE UNITED STATES?
THAT IS REALLY WHAT YOU SHOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT, NOT FICTION,
WHERE SOMEBODY WANTS FAME, AND
THEY COME OUT OF HER CRICKET
CAMPAIGN.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON.
MRS. CLINTON: EVERY TIME DONALD
HAS PUSHED ON SOMETHING, WHICH
IS OBVIOUSLY UNCOMFORTABLE, LIKE
WHAT THESE WOMEN ARE SAYING, HE
IMMEDIATELY GOES TO DENYING
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT WOMEN.
HE NEVER APOLOGIZES OR SAYS HE
IS SORRY FOR ANYTHING.
WE KNOW WHAT HE HAS SAID AND
WHAT HE HAS DONE TO WOMEN.
BUT HE ALSO WENT AFTER A
DISABLED REPORTER, MOCKED AND
BELITTLED HIM ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
HE WENT AFTER THE PARENTS OF A
YOUNG MAN WHO DIED SERVING OUR
COUNTRY, A GOLD STAR FAMILY,
BECAUSE OF THEIR RELIGION.
HE WENT AFTER JOHN MCCAIN, A
PRISONER OF WAR, SAYS HE PREFERS
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT CAPTURED.
HE WENT AFTER A FEDERAL JUDGE
BORN IN INDIANA, BUT WHO DONALD
SAID COULD NOT BE TRUSTED TO TRY
THE FRAUD AND RACKETEERING CASE
AGAINST TRUMP UNIVERSITY BECAUSE
HIS PARENTS WERE MEXICAN.
IT IS NOT ONE THING, IT IS A
PATTERN.
PATTERN OF DIVISIVENESS, OF A
VERY DARK AND IN MANY WAYS
DANGEROUS VISION OF OUR COUNTRY,
WHERE HE INCITES VIOLENCE, WHERE
HE APPLAUDS PEOPLE WHO ARE
PUSHING AND PULLING AT HIS
RALLIES.
THAT IS NOT WHAT AMERICA IS.
I HOPE AS WE MOVE IN THE LAST
WEEKS OF THIS CAMPAIGN, MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE WILL UNDERSTAND WHAT
IS AT STAKE IN THIS ELECTION.
IT REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO WHAT
TYPE OF COUNTRY WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE.
MR. TRUMP: WHEN SHE TALKS ABOUT
VIOLENCE AND MY RALLIES, SHE
CAUSED THE VIOLENCE.
THE OTHER THINGS ARE FALSE, BUT
HONESTLY, I WOULD LOVE TO TALK
ABOUT GETTING RID OF ISIS AND
OTHER THINGS.
THOSE OTHER CHARGES AS SHE KNOWS
ARE AWFUL.
MR. WALLACE: THIS IS ABOUT
FITNESS TO BE PRESIDENT, A LOT
OF DEVELOPMENTS OVER THE LAST 10
DAYS SINCE THE LAST DEBATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THEM, QUESTIONS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE.
SECRETARY CLINTON, DURING YOUR
2009 SENATE CONFIRMATION HEARING
YOU MANAGED TO AVOID EVEN THE
APPEARANCE OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST IN YOUR DEALINGS WITH
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION WHILE YOU
WERE SECRETARY OF STATE.
BUT E-MAIL SHOW DONORS HAVE
SPECIAL ACCESS YOU.
THEY WERE CONSIDERED SEPARATELY
FROM NON-DONORS AND SOME OF
THOSE DONORS BUT GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS, SPENT -- TEXT BY HER
MIGHT.
CAN YOU REALLY SAY YOU CAP YOUR
PLEDGE AND WHY HASN'T WHAT
HAPPENED IN WHAT WENT ON BETWEEN
YOU AND THE CLINTON FOUNDATION,
WHY IS IT WHAT MR. TRUMP CALLS,
PAY TO PLAY?
MRS. CLINTON: EVERYTHING I DID
AS SECRETARY OF STATE WAS IN
FURTHERANCE OF OUR COUNTRY AND
OUR VALUES.
THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN.
BUT I'M HAPPY COME IN FACT I AM
THRILLED TO TALK ABOUT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION BECAUSE IT IS
A WORLD-RENOWNED CHARITY.
I AM SO PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
IT DOES.
I COULD TALK FOR THE REST OF THE
DEBATE, I KNOW I DON'T HAVE THE
TIME TO DO THAT, BUT JUST
BRIEFLY, THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR 11 MILLION
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD WITH
HIV-AIDS TO AFFORD TREATMENT,
AND THAT IS ABOUT HALF OF ALL
THE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD WERE
GETTING TREATMENT.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AMERICAN
HEALTH ASSOCIATION WE HAD MADE
ENVIRONMENTS IN SCHOOLS
HEALTHIER.
MR. WALLACE: ESPECIALLY, THIS IS
AN OPEN DISCUSSION.
THE SPECIFIC QUESTION WENT TO
PAY FOR FLIGHT.
THE WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT?
MR. TRUMP: IT HAS BEEN VERY WELL
STUDIED.
MR. WALLACE: PLEASE LET MR.
TRUMP SPAIN.
MR. TRUMP: IT IS A CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE.
SAUDI ARABIA GIVING $25 BILLION.
YOU TALK ABOUT WOMEN AND WOMEN'S
RIGHTS?
THESE ARE ABLE TO PUSH GAYS OFF
BUILDINGS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT KILL WOMEN
AND TREAT WOMEN HORRIBLY, YET
YOU TAKE THEIR MONEY.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU RIGHT
NOW, WHY GO YOU GIVE THAT THE
MONEY THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN FROM
CERTAIN COUNTRIES THAT TREAT
CERTAIN GROUPS OF PEOPLE SO
HORRIBLY?
WHY DON'T YOU GIVE BACK THE
MONEY?
I THINK IT WOULD BE A GREAT
GESTURE.
BECAUSE SHE TAKES A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY -- TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PEOPLE OF HAITI.
I WAS IN LITTLE HAITI AND THEY
HATE THE CLINTONS.
BECAUSE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
HAITI WITH THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION IS A DISGRACE.
AND YOU KNOW IT AND THEY KNOW IT
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON.
MRS. CLINTON: WE GET THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION SPEND 90% OF ALL THE
MONEY THAT IS DONATED ON BEHALF
OF PROGRAMS AND PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD AND IN OUR OWN
COUNTRY.
I AM VERY PROUD OF THAT.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST RATING FROM
THE WATCHDOGS THAT FOLLOWED
FOUNDATIONS, AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO COMPARE WHAT WE DO WITH
THE TRUMP FOUNDATION, WHICH TOOK
MONEY FROM OTHER PEOPLE AND
BOUGHT A SIX FOOT PORTRAIT OF
DONALD.
WHO DOES THAT?
IT WAS JUST ASTONISHING.
HAITI IS THE POOREST COUNTRY IN
OUR HEMISPHERE.
THE EARTHQUAKE AND THE
HURRICANES HAVE DEVASTATED
HAITI.
BILL AND I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO HELP HAITI FOR MANY
YEARS.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION RAISED
$30 MILLION TO HELP HAITI AFTER
THE CATASTROPHIC EARTHQUAKE AND
ALL THE TERRIBLE PROBLEMS THE
PEOPLE THERE HAD.
WE HAVE DONE THINGS TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES, AGRICULTURAL
AND SO MUCH ELSE.
AND WE WILL KEEP WORKING TO HELP
HAITI BECAUSE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PART --
MR. TRUMP: I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION ONE THING.
THE TRUMP FOUNDATION, SMALL
FOUNDATION.
PEOPLE CONTRIBUTE, I CONTRIBUTED
THE MUDDY 100% GOES TO DIFFERENT
CHARITIES, INCLUDING A LOT OF
MILITARY.
I DON'T GET ANYTHING.
I DON'T BUY BOATS COME I DO NOT
BUY PLANTS.
MR. WALLACE: WAS IN SOME OF THE
MONEY USED TO SETTLE YOUR
LAWSUITS?
MR. TRUMP: WE PUT UP THE
AMERICAN FLAG AND THAT WAS IT.
WE FOUGHT FOR THE RIGHT IN PALM
BEACH TO PUT UP THE FLAG.
MR. WALLACE: THERE WAS A PENALTY
IMPOSED BY PALM BEACH COUNTY AND
THE MONEY CAME FROM YOUR
FOUNDATION.
MR. TRUMP: THE MONEY WENT TO
FISHER HOUSE, WHERE THEY BUILD
HOUSES -- THE MONEY YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN TO FISHER
HOUSE WHERE THEY BUILD HOUSES
FOR VETERANS AND DISABLED
PEOPLE.
MRS. CLINTON: THERE'S NO WAY
WHETHER WE CAN KNOW WHETHER THAT
IS TRUE BECAUSE HE IS NOT
RELEASE HIS TAX RETURNS.
HE IS THE FIRST CANDIDATE EVER
TO RUN WHO HAS NOT RELEASED HIS
TAX RETURNS.
EVERYTHING HE SAYS ABOUT CHARITY
OR ANYTHING ELSE, WE CANNOT
PROVE IT.
YOU CAN LOOK AT HOW TAX RETURNS,
WE HAVE THEM ALL OUT THERE.
BUT WHAT IS REALLY TROUBLING IS
THAT WE LEARNED IN THE LAST
DEBATE, HE IS NOT PAID A PENNY
IN FEDERAL INCOME TAX.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IMMIGRANTS
A FEW MINUTES AGO, YOU KNOW,
HALF OF ALL UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS AND OUR COUNTRY
ACTUALLY PAY FEDERAL INCOME TAX.
WE HAVE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
IN AMERICA CORP. A MORE FEDERAL
INCOME TAX THAN A BILLIONAIRE.
I FIND THAT ASTONISHING.
MR. TRUMP: WE ARE ENTITLED
BECAUSE OF THE LAWS OF PEOPLE
LIKE HER PAST TO TAKE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF DEPRECIATION ON
CHARGES, AND WE DO IT.
ALL OF OUR DONORS -- I KNOW
BUFFETT TOOK HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
MOST OF OUR DONORS HAVE DONE THE
SAME THING AS I DO.
AND YOU KNOW SHE SHOULD HAVE
DONE?
YOU SHOULD HAVE CHANGED THE LAW
WHEN YOU ARE A UNITED STATES
SENATOR.
BECAUSE YOUR DONORS AND YOUR
SPECIAL INTERESTS ARE DOING THE
SAME THING AS I DO COME EXPECT
-- EXCEPT EVEN MORE SO.
YOU'LL NOT CHANGE THE LAW
BECAUSE YOU TAKEN SO MUCH MONEY.
I SAT IN MY APARTMENT TODAY ON A
VERY BEAUTIFUL HOTEL DOWN THE
STREET --
MRS. CLINTON: DATE WITH CHINESE
-- PAID FIWH -- PAID WITH
CHINESE STEEL.
MR. TRUMP: I WATCHED AD AFTER AD
PAID FOR BY YOUR FRIENDS ON WALL
STREET.
IF YOU DO NOT LIKE WHAT I DID
YOU SHOULD CHANGE THE LAWS.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP I WANT TO
ASK YOU ONE LAST QUESTION IN
THIS TOPIC.
YOU HAVE BEEN WARNING IN RALLIES
RECENTLY THAT THIS ELECTION IS
RATE -- IS RIGGED AND HILLARY
CLINTON IS IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO STEAL IT FROM YOU.
YOUR RUNNING MATE, GOVERNOR
PENCE, PLEDGED ON SUNDAY THAT HE
AND YOU, HIS WORDS, WILL
ABSOLUTELY ACCEPT THE RESULT OF
THIS ELECTION.
TODAY GO DAUGHTER IVANKA SAID
THE SAME THING.
I WANT TO ASK YOU HERE ON THE
STAGE TONIGHT, THE SAME
COMMITMENT THAT YOU WILL
ABSOLUTELY, SIR, THEY WILL
ABSOLUTELY ACCEPT THE RESULT OF
THIS ELECTION?
MR. TRUMP: I WILL LOOK AT IT AT
THE TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT I HAVE SEEN IT SO BAD.
FIRST OF ALL, THE MEDIA SO
DISHONEST AND SO CORRUPT AND THE
SUN -- THE PYLON IS SO AMAZING,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ACTUALLY
WROTE AN ARTICLE ON IT.
IT IS SO DISHONEST.
THEY POISON THE MINDS OF THE
VOTERS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEM COME I
THINK THE VOTERS ARE SEEING
THROUGH IT.
WE WILL FIND OUT ON NOVEMBER 8
THINK THE THEATER.
EXCUSE ME, CHRIS.
IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR PHOTO ROLES,
YOU WILL SEE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE REGISTERED TO VOTE --
MILLIONS, THIS IS NOT COMING
FROM ME, THIS IS COMING FROM
OTHER PLACES -- MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE REGISTERED TO
VOTE THAT SHOULD NOT BE
REGISTERED TO VOTE.
SO, LET JUST GIVE YOU ONE OTHER
THING.
I TALKED ABOUT THE CORRUPT
MEDIA, I TALK ABOUT THE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE.
ONE OTHER THING -- SHE SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO RUN.
SHE IS GUILTY OF A VERY, VERY
SERIOUS CRIME.
SHE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
RUN.
AND JUST IN THAT RESPECT, I SAY,
IT IS RIGGED.
CHRIS, SHE SHOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED TO RUN FOR THE
PRESIDENCY BASED ON WHAT SHE DID
WITH E-MAILS AND SO MANY OTHER
THINGS.
MR. WALLACE: I'M SORRY, THERE IS
A TRADITION IN THIS COUNTRY, IN
FACT ONE OF THE PRIZE OF THIS
COUNTRY IS THE DIESEL TRANSITION
OF POWER IN THAT NO MATTER HOW
HARD FOR A CAMPAIGN IS THAT AT
THE END OF THE CAMPAIGN, THAT
THE LOSER CONCEDES TO THE
WINNER.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE THE
LOSER OR THE WINNER, THE LOSER
CONCEDES TO THE WINNER AND THE
COUNTRY COMES TOGETHER IN PART
FOR THE GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
ARE YOU SAYING YOU ARE NOT
PREPARED TO DO THAT?
MR. TRUMP: I WILL TELL YOU AT
THE TIME, I WILL KEEP YOU IN
SUSPENSE.
MRS. CLINTON: LET A RESPONSE TO
THAT, BECAUSE THAT IS
HORRIFYING.
EVERY TIME DONALD THINKS THINGS
ARE NOT GOING IN HIS DIRECTION,
HE CLAIMS WHATEVER IT IS IS RATE
AGAINST HIM.
THE FBI CONDUCTED -- RIGGED
HE LOST IOWA, HE SAID REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY WAS RIGGED.
TRIBUNE DIVERSITY GETS SUED FOR
FRAUD AND RACKETEERING, HE
CLAIMS THE COURSES ARE ANDY
FEDERAL JUDGES ARE RIGGED
AGAINST HIM.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN HE DID NOT
GET AN EMMY FOR HIS TV PROGRAM
AND HE CLAIMED THE EMMYS WERE
RIGGED.
MR. TRUMP: I SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
MRS. CLINTON: IT IS FUNNY BUT IT
IS ALSO REALLY TROUBLING.
WE HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR 240
YEARS.
WE HAVE HAD FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS.
WE HAVE ACCEPTED THE OUTCOME
WHAT WE MAY NOT HAVE LIKED THEM.
THAT IS WHAT MUST BE EXCEPTED OF
ANYONE STANDING ON A DEBATE
STAGE DURING A GENERAL ELECTION.
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID THE OTHER
DAY, WHEN YOU ARE WHINING, IT
JUST SHOWS THAT YOU'RE NOT UP TO
DOING THE JOB.
MUST BE EXCEPTED OF
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT HE IS
SAYING AND WHAT THAT MEANS -- HE
IS DENIGRATING, HE IS TALKING
DOWN OUR DEMOCRACY, AND I FOR 1
AM APPALLED THAT SOMEBODY WHO IS
THE NOMINEE OF ONE OF OUR MAJOR
PARTIES WOULD TAKE THE KIND OF
POSITION.
MR. TRUMP: I THINK WITH THE FBI
DID IN WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DID, INCLUDING MEETING
WITH HER HUSBAND, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN THE BACK OF AN
AIRPLANE IN ARIZONA -- I THINK
IT IS DISGRACEFUL.
I THINK IT IS A DISGRACE.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A SITUATION SO
THAT -- SO BAD.
MR. WALLACE: LET'S PLEASE
CONTINUE THE DEBATE AND MOVE ON
TO THE SUBJECT OF FOREIGN
HOTSPOTS.
IRAQI DEFENSIVE TO TAKE BACK
MOSUL HAS BEGUN.
IF THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
PUSHING ISIS OUT OF THAT CITY
AND OUT OF ALL OF IRAQ, THE
QUESTION THEN BECOMES, WHAT
HAPPENS THE DAY AFTER?
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WHOEVER
OF VIEW ENDS UP AS PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO HAVE TO CONFRONT.
WILL YOU PUT U.S. TROOPS INTO
THAT VACUUM TO MAKE SURE THAT
ISIS DOES NOT COME BACK OR IS
NOT REPLACED BY SOMETHING EVEN
WORSE?
SECRETARY CLINTON, YOU GO FIRST,
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
MRS. CLINTON: I AM ENCOURAGED
THAT THERE IS AN EFFORT LED BY
THE IRAQI ARMY, SUPPORTED BY
KURDISH FORCES AND ALSO GIVEN
THE ADVICE FROM A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL FORCES AND OTHER
AMERICANS ON THE GROUND.
BUT I WILL NOT SUPPORT PUTTING
AMERICAN SOLDIERS INTO IRAQ AS
AN OCCUPYING FORCE.
I DO NOT THINK THAT IS AN OUT
INTEREST AND I DO NOT THINK THAT
WOULD BE SMART TO DO.
IN FACT, CHRIS, I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A BIG RED FLAG WAVING
FOR ISIS TO RECONSTITUTE ITSELF.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO TAKE BACK
MOSUL.
IT IS GOING TO BE A HARD FIGHT,
I HAVE NO ILLUSIONS ABOUT THAT.
THEN CONTINUE TO PRESSURE INTO
SYRIA TO BEGIN TO TAKE BACK AND
MOVE ON ROCCA, WHICH IS THE ISIS
HEADQUARTERS.
I AM HOPEFUL THAT THE HARD WORK
THAT AMERICAN MILITARY ADVISERS
HAVE DONE WILL PAY OFF IN THAT
WE WILL SEE A REALLY SUCCESSFUL
MILITARY OPERATION.
BUT WE KNOW WE HAVE LOTS OF WORK
TO DO.
SYRIA WILL REMAIN A HOTBED OF
TERRORISM AS LONG AS THE CIVIL
WAR, AIDED AND ABETTED BY THE
IRANIANS AND THE RUSSIANS,
CONTINUE.
I HAVE SAID WE NEED TO KEEP OUR
EYE ON ISIS, THAT IS WHY I WANT
TO HAVE AN INTELLIGENCE SURGE
THAT PROTECTS US HERE AT HOME.
WHAT WE HAVE TO GO AFTER THEM
FROM THE AIR, ON THE GROUND COME
ONLINE.
WHILE IT HAVE TO MAKE SURE HERE
KNOW WE DO NOT LET TERRORISTS
BUY WEAPONS.
IF YOU ARE TOO DANGEROUS TO FLY,
YOU'RE TOO DANGEROUS TO BUY A
GUN.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
FOR A NO-FLY ZONE AND SAFE
HAVENS WITHIN SYRIA, NOT ONLY TO
HELP PROTECT THE SYRIANS AND
PREVENT THE CONSTANT OUTFLOW OF
REFUGEES, BUT TO FRANKLY GAINS
AND LEVERAGE ON BOTH THE SYRIAN
GOVERNMENT AND THE RUSSIANS OF
THAT PERHAPS WE CAN HAVE THE
KIND OF SERIOUS NEGOTIATION
NECESSARY TO BRING THE CONFLICT
TO AN END AND GO FORWARD ON A
POLITICAL TRACK.
MR. WALLACE: MR. TRUMP, SAME
QUESTION.
IF WE ARE ABLE TO PUSH ISIS OUT
OF MOSUL AND IRAQ, WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO PUT U.S. TROOPS IN
THERE TO PREVENT THEIR RETURN OR
SOMETHING ELSE?
MR. TRUMP: LET ME TELL YOU,
MOSUL IS SO SAD.
WE HAD MOSUL, BUT WHEN SHE TOOK
EVERYONE OUT WE LOST MOSUL.
WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO IS THEY
WANTED TO GET THE LEADERS OF
ISIS, WHO THEY FELT WERE IN
MOSUL.
ABOUT THREE MONTHS AGO I STARTED
READING THEY WANTED TO GET THE
LEADERS AND THEY ARE GOING TO
ATTACK MOSUL.
FELT WEREWHATEVER HAPPENED TO T
OF SURPRISE?
WE ANNOUNCE WE'RE GOING AFTER
MOSUL.
I'VE BEEN READING IT FOR, HOW
LONG IS IT HILLARY?
THREE MONTHS?
THEY HAVE ALL LEFT.
THE ELEMENT OF SURPRISE.
DOUGLAS MACARTHUR, GEORGE
PATTON, SPINNING IN THEIR GRAVES
WHEN THEY SEE THE STUPIDITY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
ALL SHE HAD TO DO WAS STAY
THERE, NOW WE'RE GOING IN AGAIN.
BUT YOU KNOW THE BIG WINNER IN
MOSUL WILL BE AFTER WE
EVENTUALLY GET IT?
AND THE ONLY REASON THEY DID IS
BECAUSE SHE IS RUNNING FORBUT YN
THE
OFFICE OF PRESIDENT AND THEY
WANT TO LOOK TOUGH, THEY WANT TO
LOOK GOOD.
SHE VIOLATED THE RED LINE IN THE
SAND AND SHE MADE SO MANY
MISTAKES.
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE THE GREAT
MIGRATION.
BUT SHE WANTED TO LOOK GOOD FOR
THE ELECTION, SO THEY ARE GOING
IN.
IT WAS GOOD TO GET MOSUL, REAL
LY?
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE IT COME
EVENTUALLY.
MUCH TOUGHER THAN I THOUGHT.
MUCH MORE DANGEROUS.
MORE DEATHS THAN A THOUGHT.
BUT THE LEADERS WANTED TO GET
PERL GONE BECAUSE THEY ARE
SMART.
WHAT DO WE NEED THIS FOR?
MOSUL IS GOING TO BE A WONDERFUL
THING AND IRAN SHOULD WRITE US A
LETTER OF FACEBOOK.
THE STUPIDEST DEAL OF ALL-TIME.
A DEAL THAT WOULD GIVE IRAN
ABSOLUTELY NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THEY SHOULD WRITE US YET ANOTHER
LETTER SAYING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BECAUSE IRAN, AS I SAID
MANY YEARS AGO, IRAN IS TAKING
OVER IRAQ.
SOMETHING THEY WANT TO DO
FOREVER AND WE MADE SO EASY FOR
THEM.
YOU KNOW WHO IS GOING TO BE THE
BENEFICIARY?
IRAN.
BOY, THEY ARE OUTSMARTING --
YOU'RE NOT THERE, YOU MIGHT NOT
BE INVOLVED IN THAT DECISION,
BUT YOU WERE THERE WHEN YOU TOOK
EVERYBODY OUT OF MOSUL AND IRAQ.
YOU VOTED FOR.
-- FOR IT.
ONCE YOU LEFT YOU SHOULD HAVE
NEVER --
MRS. CLINTON: ONCE AGAIN, DONALD
IS IMPLYING THAT HE DID NOT
SUPPORT THE INVASION OF IRAQ.
I SAID IT WAS A MISTAKE AND SAID
THAT YEARS AGO.
HE HAS CONSISTENTLY DENIED IT
WAS A VERY CLEAR FACT THAT
BEFORE THE INVASION HE SUPPORTED
IT.
YOU KNOW, I JUST WANT EVERYBODY
TO GOOGLE IT.
GOOGLE DONALD TRUMP IRAQ, AND
YOU WILL SEE DOZENS OF SOURCES
VERIFIED HE WAS FOR THE INVASION
OF IRAQ AND YOU CAN NATURALLY
HEAR THE AUDIO OF THEM SAYING
THAT.
WHY DOES THAT MATTER?
IT MATTERS BECAUSE HE HAS NOT
TOLD THE TRUTH ABOUT THAT
POSITION.
I GUESS HE BELIEVES IT MAKES HIM
LOOK BETTER NOW TO CONTRAST WITH
ME BECAUSE I DID VOTE FOR IT.
BUT WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
HERE IS TO UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE
INTERPLAY.
MOSUL IS A SUNNI CITY, MOSUL IS
ON THE BORDER OF SYRIA AND YES,
WE DO NEED TO GO AFTER BAD DADDY
-- BAGDADHI JUST LIKE WE WENT
AFTER BIN LADEN WHILE YOU ARE
DOING "CELEBRITY APPRENTICE."
WE NEED TO GET RID OF THEM COME
OTHER FIGHTERS, THEIR ESTIMATED
SEVERAL THOUSAND FIGHTERS IN
MOSUL.
THEY HAVE BEEN DIGGING
UNDERGROUND, THEY HAD BEEN
PREPARED TO DEFEND.
IT WILL BE TOUGH.
WE CAN TAKE OVERWE NEED TO GET N
TAKE BACK ROCCA.
I AM JUST AMAZED THAT HE SEEMS
TO THINK THE IRAQI GOVERNMENT
AND OUR ALLIES AND EVERYBODY
ELSE LAUNCHED THE ATTACK ON
MOSUL TO HELP ME IN THE
ELECTION, BUT THAT IS HOW DONALD
THINKS.
HE IS ALWAYS LOOKING --
MR. TRUMP: BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED
ANYTHING.
IRAN IS TAKING OVER IRAQ.
WE WOULD HAVE GAINED --
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON,
IT IS AN OPEN DISCUSSION.
MRS. CLINTON: HE IS UNFIT AND HE
PROVES IT EVERY TIME.
WIKILEAKS JUST ACTUALLY CAME OUT
--
MR. TRUMP: WIKILEAKS JUST CAME
OUT, WIKILEAKS -- JOHN PODESTA
SAID SOME HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
YOU.
BERNIE SANDERS AND YOU HAD BAD
JUDGMENT, YOU DO.
IF YOU THINK THAT GOING INTO
MOSUL AFTER WE LET THE WORLD
KNOW WE WERE GOING INCOME AND
ALL THE PEOPLE WE REALLY WANTED,
THE LEADERS ARE ALL GONE.
IF YOU THINK THAT WAS GOOD, AND
YOU DO.
JOHN PODESTA SAID YOU HAD
TERRIBLE AND SIX.
BERNIE SANDERS AND YOU HAD BAD
JUDGMENT.
I AGREE WITH BOTH.
MRS. CLINTON: WELL, YOU SHOULD
ASK BERNIE SANDERS WHO HE IS
SUPPORTING FOR PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE THE MOST DANGEROUS
PERSON TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
THE MODERN HISTORY OF AMERICA.
I THINK HE IS RIGHT.
MR. WALLACE: LET'S TURN TO A
LEVEL.
[LAUGHTER]
-- TO ALLEPPO.
IN THE LAST OF IT WERE BOTH
ASKED ABOUT THE SITUATION IN THE
SYRIAN CITY OF ALEPPO AND I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT BECAUSE YOU
SAID SEVERAL THINGS IN A DEBATE
THAT WERE NOT TRUE.
HE SAID A LEVEL HAS BASICALLY
FALLEN.
-- ALLEPO HAS FALLEN
MR. TRUMP: HAVE YOU SEEN IT?
HAVE YOU SEEN WHAT HAS HAPPENED
TO ALEPPO?
SO, IT HASN'T FALLEN?
TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
THEY ARE BEING SLAUGHTERED
BECAUSE OF BAD DECISIONS.
MR. WALLACE: IF I MAY FINISH
YEAR.
YOU HAVE ALSO SAID THAT SYRIA IN
RUSSIA ARE BUSY FIGHTING ISIS,
IN FACT THEY HAD BEEN THE ONES
WHO HAVE BEEN BOMBING AND
SHELLING EASTERN ALEPPO.
THEY JUST ANNOUNCE ANIMATE -- A
PAUSE ADMITTING THAT THEY HAD
BEEN BOMBING ALEPPO.
MR. TRUMP: ALEPPO IS A DISASTER.
IT IS A HUMANITARIAN NIGHTMARE
BUT IT HAS FALLEN FROM ANY
SAMPLING.
DO YOU NEED A SIGNED DOCUMENT?
IT IS SO SAD.
A LOT OF THIS IS BECAUSE OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
BECAUSE WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS BY
FIGHTING ASSAD, WHO TURNED OUT
TO BE A LOT TOUGHER THAN HE
THOUGHT -- NOW SHE IS GOING TO
SAY IT ALL, HE LOVES ASSAD.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE MUCH SMARTER
THAN HER AND OBAMA.
HE ALIGNED WITH RUSSIA, HE NOW
ALSO ALIGNED WITH IRAN, WHO WE
MAY VERY POWERFUL.
WE GAVE THEM $150 BILLION BACK.
$1.7 BILLION IN CASH.
BUNCDLES OF CASH AS BIG AS THIS
STAGE.
NOW HE HAS ALIGNED WITH RUSSIA
IN WITH -- AND WITH IRAN.
THEY DON'T WANT ISIS WHAT THEY
HAVE OTHER THINGS BECAUSE WE ARE
BACKING REBELS.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHO THE REBELS
ARE.
WE ARE GIVING THEM LOTS OF
MONEY, LOTS OF EVERYTHING.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHO THE REBELS
ARE.
AND WHEN AND IF -- YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE YOU HAVE
RUSSIA AND IRAN -- WHAT IF THEY
EVER DID OVERTHROW ASSAD -- AND
HE'S A BAD GUY -- BUT YOU MIGHT
END UP WITH WORSE THAN ASSAD.
IF SHE DID NOTHING WE WOULD BE
IN BETTER SHAPE.
THIS IS WHAT HAS CAUSED THE
GREAT MIGRATION, WHERE SHE IS
TAKING IN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
SYRIAN REFUGEES, WHO PROBABLY --
IN MANY CASES -- INDEFINITELY --
ARE DEFINITELY ISIS-ALLIGNED.
THIS'LL BE THE GREAT TROJAN
HORSE.
WAIT TILL YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE COMING YEARS.
LOTS OF LUCK.
THANKS A LOT FOR DOING A GREAT
JOB.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON,
YOU HAVE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
IMPOSING A NO-FLY ZONE TO TRY TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF ALEPPO AND
STOP THE KILLING THERE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS REFUSED TO
DO THAT BECAUSE HE FEARS HE WILL
DRAWS DEEPER INTO THE CONFLICT.
AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE GENERAL
CHIEF OF STAFF SAYS YOU PROPOSE
A NEW -- NO-FLY ZONE, CHANCES
ARE YOU WILL GET INTO IT -- A
WAR WITH SYRIA IN RUSSIA.
IF YOU IMPOSE A NO-FLY ZONE,
FIRST OF ALL HOW DO YOU RESPOND
TO THEIR CONCERNS -- SECONDLY,
IF YOU IMPOSE A NO-FLY ZONE AND
EIGHT RUSSIAN PLANE DIVIDES
THAT, DO YOU SHOOT DOWN THE
PLANE?
MRS. CLINTON: FIRST OF ALL, A
NO-FLY ZONE COULD HASTEN THE END
OF THE CONFLICT AND SAVE LIVES.
I AM AWARE OF THE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS YOU HAVE EXPRESSED FROM
BOTH THE PRESIDENT AND THE
GENERAL.
THIS WOULD NOT BE DONE JUST ON
THE FIRST DAY.
THIS WOULD TAKE A LOT OF
NEGOTIATION.
IT WOULD ALSO TAKE MAKING IT
CLEAR TO PRESSURE IN SYRIA THAT
OUR PURPOSE HERE WAS TO PROVIDE
SAFE ZONES ON THE GROUND.
WE HAVE HAD MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
LEAVE SYRIA AND THOSE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE INSIDE SYRIA WHO HAVE
BEEN DISLOCATED.
I THINK WE COULD STRIKE A DEAL
AND MAKE IT VERY CLEAR TO THE
RUSSIANS AND THE SYRIANS THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
BELIEVE IS OF THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND IN
SYRIA.
IT WOULD HELP US IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST ISIS.
BUT I WANT TO RESPOND TO WHAT
DONALD SAID ABOUT REFUGEES.
HE HAS MADE THESE CLAIMS
REPEATEDLY.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET ANYONE INTO
THIS COUNTRY WHO WAS NOT VETTED,
WE DO NOT HAVE CONFIDENCE IN.
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO SLAM THE
DOOR ON WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
THAT PICTURE OF THAT LITTLE
FOUR-YEAR-OLD BOY IN ALEPPO WITH
THE BLOOD COMING DOWN HIS FACE
WHILE HE SAT IN AN AMULET IS
HAUNTING.
WE'RE GOING TO DO VERY CAREFUL,
THOROUGH VETTING.
THAT IS NOT SOLVE OUR INTERNAL
CHALLENGES WITH ISIS AND OUR
NEED TO STOP RADICALIZATION.
TO WORK WITH AN AMERICAN MUSLIM
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES TO IDENTIFY AND PREVENT
ATTACKS.
IN FACT, THE KILLER OF THE
DOZENS OF PEOPLE AT THE
NIGHTCLUB IN ORLANDO, THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB, WAS BORN IN QUEENS,
THE SAME PLACE DONALD WAS BORN.
SO, LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
THE THREAT IS AND HOW WE ARE
GOING TO BEST BE ABLE TO MEET
APPEARED YESTERDAY SOME OF THAT
THREAT EMANATES FROM SYRIA AND
IRAQ AND WE HAVE TO KEEP
FIGHTING AND I WILL DEFEAT ISIS.
IN SOME OF THAT IS WE HAVE TO UP
OUR GAME AND MUCH SMARTER AT
HOME.
MR. WALLACE: I WANT TO GET INTO
OUR FINAL SEGMENT.
MR. TRUMP: IT IS SO RIDICULOUS
-- SHE WILL DEFEAT ISIS.
WE SHOULD NEVER HAVE LET ISIS
HAPPEN IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WAIT ONE SECOND.
THEY HAD A CEASE-FIRE THROUGH
THESE AGO.
A CEASE-FIRE, UNITED STATES,
RUSSIA, SYRIA.
DURING THE CEASE-FIRE, RUSSIA
TOOK OVER VAST SWATCHES OF LAND
THAT THEY SAID WE DO NOT WANT
THE CEASE-FIRE ANYMORE.
WE ARE SO OUTPLAYED ON MISSILES,
ON CEASE-FIRES.
THEY ARE OUTPLAYED.
SHE WAS NOT THERE, I ASSUME SHE
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
BUT OUR COUNTRY IS SO OUTPLAYED
BY PUTIN AND ASSAD, BY THE WAY,
AND BY IRAN.
NOBODY CAN BELIEVE HOW STUPID
OUR LEADERSHIP IS.
MR. WALLACE: NO, WE NEED TO MOVE
ON TO OUR FINAL SEGMENT AND THAT
IS THE NATIONAL DEBT, WHICH IS
NOT BEEN DISCUSSED UNTIL
TONIGHT.
OUR NATIONAL DEBT, OUR GDP IS
NOW 77%.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST SINCE JUST
AFTER WORLD WAR II.
WITH A NONPARTISAN COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE GOVERNMENT SAYS
SECRETARY CLINTON, UNDER YOUR
PLAN, THAT WOULD RISE TO 86% OF
GDP OVER THE NEXT 10 POINT YES
10 YEARS.
MR. TRUMP THEY SAY IT WOULD RISE
TO 105% OF GDP.
THE QUESTION IS, WHY ARE BOTH OF
YOU IGNORING THIS PROBLEM?
MR. TRUMP, YOU GO FIRST.
MR. TRUMP: THEY ARE WRONG
BECAUSE I GO TO GREAT TREMENDOUS
JOBS.
WE ARE BRINGING GDP FROM 1%,
WHICH IS WHAT IT IS NOW, AND IF
SHE GOT IN IT WILL BE LESS THAN
ZERO.
WE ARE BRINGING IT UP TO 4% AND
I THINK WE CAN NATURALLY GO
HIGHER.
I THINK WE CAN GO TO 5% OR 6%.
IF WE DO, YOU DO NOT HAVE TO
BOTHER ASKING YOUR QUESTION
BECAUSE WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
MACHINE.
WE HAVE CREATED A TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC MACHINE ONCE AGAIN.
TO DO THAT, WE ARE TAKING BACK
JOBS, WE GOING TO LET OUR
COMPANIES HE RATED BY OTHER
COUNTRIES WHERE WE LOSE ALL OUR
JOBS.
THAT IS VERY SAD.
BUT I'M GOING TO CREATE THE KIND
OF COUNTRY THAT WE WERE FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF INDUSTRY.
WE USED TO BE THERE.
WE HAVE GIVEN IT UP.
WE HAVE BECOME VERY, VERY
SLOPPY.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
POLITICAL HACKS MAKING THE
BIGGEST DEALS IN THE WORLD,
BIGGER THAN COMPANIES.
YOU TAKE THESE BIG COMPANIES,
THE TRADE DEALS ARE FAR BIGGER
THAN HIS COMPANIES.
GET WE DO NOT USE OUR GREAT
LEADERS, MANY OF WHOM BACKED ME
AND MANY OF WHOM BACK HILLARY, I
MUST SAY.
BUT WE DO NOT USE THOSE PEOPLE.
THESE ARE THE GREATEST
NEGOTIATORS IN THE WORLD.
THE HAVE THE GREATEST BUSINESS
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
CAP TO USE THEM TO NEGOTIATE OUR
TRADE DEALS.
WE USE POLITICAL HACKS.
WE AS PEOPLE WHO GET THE
POSITION BECAUSE THEY MADE A
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
THEY ARE DEALING WITH CHINA AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY MUCH SMARTER
THAN THEY ARE.
WE HAVE TO USE OUR GREAT PEOPLE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, WE WILL
CREATE AN ECONOMIC MACHINE, THE
LIKES OF WHICH WE HAVE NOT SEEN
IN MANY DECADES.
AND PEOPLE, CHRIS, WILL AGAIN GO
BACK TO WORK AND THEY WILL MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY IN WILL HAVE
COMPANIES THAT WILL GROW AND
EXPAND AND START FROM THERE.
MR. WALLACE: SECRETARY CLINTON.
MRS. CLINTON: FIRST, WHEN I HEAR
DONALD TALK ABOUT THAT AND WHEN
I HEAR IS LOADED IS MIKE -- MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, I WONDER
WHEN YOU THINK AMERICA WAS
GREAT.
RUSSIA SAYS BEFORE YOU IN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS THERE, I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT HE HAS BEEN
CRITICIZING OUR GOVERNMENT FOR
DECADES.
BACK IN 1987, HE TOOK OUT A
$100,000 AT IN "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" DURING THE TIME WHEN
PRESIDENT REAGAN WAS PRESIDENT,
IN BASICALLY SAID EXACTLY WHAT
HE JUST SAID NOW, THAT WE WERE
THE LAUGHINGSTOCK OF THE WORLD.
HE WAS CRITICIZING PRESIDENT
REAGAN.
THIS IS THE WAY DONALD THINKS
ABOUT HIMSELF.
HE PUTS HIMSELF INTO THE MIDDLE
AND SAYS, YOU KNOW, I ALONE CAN
FIX IT, AS HE SAID AT THE
CONVENTION STAGE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEBT,
WHICH IS THE ISSUE YOU ASKED
ABOUT, CHRIS, I PAY FOR
EVERYTHING I AM PROPOSING.
I DO NOT ADD A SINGLE PENNY TO
THE NATIONAL DEBT.
I TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT IS ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE GOT TO
COME TO GRIPS WITH.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR EDUCATION, HOW
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE, HOW WE'RE GOING
TO GET BECAUSE OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS DOWN AND ALLOW THE OTHER
ISSUES PEOPLE TALK TO ME ABOUT
ALL THE TIME -- I AM GOING TO GO
WHERE THE MONEY IS.
WE ARE GOING TO ASK THE WEALTHY
AND CORPORATIONS TO PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
THAT THAT WILL SLOW DOWN OR
DIMINISH OUR GROWTH.
IN FACT, I THINK JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
WE WILL HAVE WHAT ECONOMISTS
CALL MIDDLE OUTGROWTH.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO
REBUILDING THE MIDDLE CLASS.
THE FAMILIES OF AMERICA.
THAT IS WHERE GROWTH WILL COME
FROM.
THAT IS WHY I WANT TO INVEST IN
YOU, AND YOUR FAMILY.
I THINK THAT IS THE SMARTEST WAY
TO GROW THE ECONOMY, TO MAKE THE
ECONOMY FARE.
WE JUST HAVE A BIG DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT THIS.
IT MAY BE BECAUSE OF OUR
EXPERIENCES.
HE STARTED OFF WITH HIS DAD IS A
MILLIONAIRE, I STARTED OFF WITH
MY DAD IS A SMALL BUSINESSMAN.
MR. TRUMP: WE HAVE HEARD THIS
BEFORE.
MRS. CLINTON: IT IS A DIFFERENCE
IT AFFECTS HOW WE SEE THE WORLD
AND WHAT WE WANT TO DO WITH YOU,
DEAR -- WITH .
MR. TRUMP: CAN I RESPOND?
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH TOUGHER
ON TRADE THEM.
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR YEARS.
FRANKLY, NOW WE'RE GOING TO DO
IT RIGHT.
MR. WALLACE: ONE LAST AREA I
WANT TO GET INTO WITH THIS
DEBATE IS THAT THE BIGGEST
DRIVER OF OUR DEBT IS
ENTITLEMENT, WHICH ISMR. WALLACL
FEDERAL SPENDING.
THE COMMITTEE FOR RESPONSIBLE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS LOOKED AT
BOTH ARE YOUR PLANS AND THEY SAY
NEITHER OF YOU HAS A SERIOUS
PLAN THAT WILL SOLVE THE FACT
THAT MEDICARE IS WHAT TO RUN OUT
OF MONEY IN THE 20 20'S, SOCIAL
SECURITY WILL RUN OUT OF MONEY
IN THE 20 30'S.
RECIPIENTS ARE GOING TO TAKE
HUGE CUTS OTHER BENEFITS.
IN EFFECT, THE FINAL QUESTION I
WANT TO ASK YOU -- AND LET ME
START WITH YOU, MR. TRUMP --
WOULD PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKE A
DEAL TO SAVE SOCIAL SECURITY
THAT INCLUDED TAX INCREASES AND
BENEFIT CUTS THAT WILL
IN EFFECT A GRAND BARGAIN ON
ENTITLEMENT.
MR. TRUMP: I'M CUTTING TAXES,
AND ONE THING WE HAVE TO DO --
REPEAL AND REPLACE THE DISASTER
KNOWN AS OBAMACARE.
IT IS DESTROYING OUR COUNTRY.
IT IS DESTROYING OUR BUSINESSES,
SMALL BUSINESSES AND BIG
BUSINESSES.
WE HAVE TO REPEAL AND REPLACE
OBAMACARE.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
THAT WILL COST US -- IT IS A
DISASTER.
IT IS PROBABLY GOING TO DIE OF
ITS OWN WEIGHT, BUT OBAMACARE
HAS TO GO.
PREMIUMS ARE GOING UP 60%, 70%,
80%.
NEXT YEAR, THEY WILL GO UP OVER
100%.
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT PREMIUMS
HAVE STARTED -- AT LEAST THE
PEOPLE SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING.
SHE WANTS TO KEEP OBAMACARE AND
MAKE IT EVEN WORSE AND IT CANNOT
EVEN GET WORSE.
WE HAVE TO REPEAL AND REPLACE
OBAMACARE.
CHRIS: SECRETARY CLINTON, SAME
QUESTION.
AT THIS POINT, TRUST FUNDS ARE
GOING TO RUN OUT OF MONEY.
WILL YOU, AS PRESIDENT CONSIDER
A GRAND BARGAIN, A DEAL THAT
INCLUDES BOTH TAX INCREASES AND
BENEFIT CUTS TO TRY TO SAVE BOTH
PROGRAMS?
SECRETARY CLINTON: I AM ON
RECORD AS SAYING WE NEED TO PUT
MORE MONEY IN THE SOCIAL
SECURITY TRUST FUND.
THAT IS PART OF MY COMMITMENT TO
RAISE TAXES ON THE WEALTHY.
MY SOCIAL SECURITY PAYROLL
CONTRIBUTION WILL GO UP, AS WILL
DONALD COST ASSUMING HE CANNOT
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET OUT OF IT,
BUT WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS FIGURE
OUT HOW TO REPLENISH THE TRUST
FUND --
MR. TRUMP: SUCH A NASTY WOMAN.
SECRETARY CLINTON: BY MAKING
SURE WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
REPLENISH THE TRUST FUNDS.
I WILL NOT CUT BENEFITS.
I WANT TO ENHANCE BENEFITS FOR
LOW-INCOME WORKERS AND FOR WOMEN
, WHO HAVE BEEN DISADVANTAGED BY
THE CURRENT SOCIAL SECURITY
SYSTEM.
BUT WHAT DONALD IS PROPOSING
WITH THESE MASSIVE TAX CUTS WILL
RESULT IN A $20 TRILLION
ADDITIONAL NATIONAL DEBT.
THAT WILL HAVE DIRE CONSEQUENCES
FOR SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE, AND I WILL SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT THE AFFORD OF A
CARE ACT, WHICH HE WANTS TO
REPEAL -- THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT EXTENDED THE SOLVENCY OF THE
MEDICARE TRUST FUND, SO IF HE
REPEALS IT, OUR MEDICARE PROBLEM
GETS WORSE --
MR. TRUMP: I DISAGREE.
SECRETARY CLINTON: WHAT WE NEED
OUR LONG-TERM HEALTH CARE
DRIVERS.
WE HAVE TO GET COST DOWN,
INCREASE VALUE, EMPHASIZE
WELLNESS.
I HAVE A PLAN FOR DOING THAT AND
I THINK WE WILL GET ENTITLEMENT
SPENDING UNDER CONTROL.
CHRIS: THIS IS THE FINAL TIME --
I BELIEVE TO BOTH OF YOUR
DELIGHT -- YOU WILL BE TOGETHER
ON STAGE DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE IT ON A
POSITIVE NOTE.
YOU HAVE NOT AGREED TO CLOSING
STATEMENTS, BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT MIGHT MAKE IT MORE
INTERESTING BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOT
PREPARED CLOSING STATEMENTS.
WE ARE GOING TO PUT A CLOCK UP,
ONE MINUTE, IN THE FINAL
QUESTION IN THE FINAL DEBATE TO
TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHY
THEY SHOULD ELECT YOU TO BE THE
NEXT PRESIDENT.
THIS IS ANOTHER NEW MINI
SEGMENT.
SECRETARY CLINTON, IT IS YOUR
TURN TO GO FIRST.
SECRETARY CLINTON: I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY TO EVERYONE WATCHING
TONIGHT THAT I AM REACHING OUT
TO ALL AMERICANS -- DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, INDEPENDENTS
BECAUSE WE NEED EVERYBODY TO
GROW THE ECONOMY, TO MAKE IT
FAIRER, TO MAKE IT WORK FOR
EVERYONE.
WE NEED YOUR TALENTS, SKILLS,
COMMITMENT, ENERGY, AMBITION.
I HAVE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO SEE
THE PRESIDENCY UP CLOSE, AND I
KNOW THE AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY
OF PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY AND
THE INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY OF
WORKING TO TRY TO MAKE LIFE
BETTER OR ALL OF YOU.
I HAVE MADE THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES MY LIFE'S WORK.
THAT IS WHAT MY MISSION WILL BE
IN THE PRESIDENCY.
I WILL STAND UP FOR FAMILIES
AGAINST POWERFUL INTERESTS,
AGAINST CORPORATIONS.
I WILL DO EVERYTHING I CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE GOOD
JOBS WITH RISING INCOME, THAT
YOUR KIDS HAVE GOOD EDUCATIONS
FROM PRESCHOOL THROUGH COLLEGE.
I HOPE YOU WILL GIVE ME A CHANCE
TO SERVE AS YOUR PRESIDENT.
CHRIS: SECRETARY CLINTON, THANK
YOU.
MR. TRUMP: MR. TRUMP: SHE'S
RAISING THE MONEY FROM THE
PEOPLE SHE WANTS TO CONTROL.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
I STARTED THIS CAMPAIGN, I
STARTED IT VERY STRONGLY, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN.
WE HAVE A DEPLETED MILITARY.
IT HAS TO BE ASKED.
WE DO NOT TAKE CARE OF OUR
VETERANS.
WE TAKE CARE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, PEOPLE WHO COME INTO
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, BETTER
THAN WE TAKE CARE OF OUR VETS.
THAT CANNOT HAPPEN.
OUR POLICEMEN AND WOMEN ARE
DISRESPECTED.
WE NEED LAW AND ORDER, BUT WE
NEED JUSTICE, TOO.
OUR INNER CITIES ARE A DISASTER.
YOU GET SHOT WALKING TO THE
STORE.
THEY HAVE NO EDUCATION AND NO
JOBS.
I WILL DO MORE FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND LATINOS
THAN SHE CAN EVER DO IN 10
LIFETIMES.
ALL SHE HAS EVER DONE IS TALKED
TO THE AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
LATINOS, BUT THEY GET THERE
VOTED COME BACK AND SAY WE WILL
SEE YOU IN FOUR YEARS.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE AMERICA
STRONG AGAIN AND WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, AND IT
HAS TO START NOW.
WE CANNOT TAKE FOUR MORE YEARS
OF THE BARACK OBAMA AND THAT IS
WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU GET HER.
CHRIS: THANK YOU BOTH.
HOLD ON JUST A MOMENT, FULL.
SECRETARY CLINTON, MR. TRUMP, I
WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
PARTICIPATING IN ALL THREE OF
THESE DEBATES.
THAT BRINGS TO AN END THIS
DEBATE SPONSORED BY THE
PRESIDENTIAL COMMISSION OF
DEBATES.
WE WANT TO THANK THE UNIVERSITY
OF NEVADA, LAS VEGAS, AND ITS
STUDENTS FOR HAVING US.
NOW THE DECISION IS UP TO YOU.
WHILE MILLIONS HAVE ALREADY
VOTED, ELECTION DAY, NOVEMBER 8,
IS JUST 20 DAYS AWAY.
ONE THING EVERYONE HERE CAN
AGREE ON, WE HOPE YOU WILL GO
VOTE.
IT IS ONE OF THE HONORS AND
OBLIGATIONS OF LIVING IN THIS
GREAT COUNTRY.
THANK YOU AND GOOD NIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT IS THE THIRD AND FINAL
DEBATE.
YOU SEE CHRIS WALLACE SHAKING
HANDS WITH HILLARY CLINTON.
DONALD TRUMP'S THEY IN BEHIND
THE PODIUM.
INTERESTED TO WHAT HAPPENS
THERE, BUT THIS IS AN EVENING
WITH A LOT OF SUBSTANCE AND A
LOT OF DISCUSSION OF THE TOPICS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE NEWS OF
LATE.
FOR HER, THE WIKILEAKS
DOCUMENTS.
FOR HIM, ALLEGATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE AGAINST HIM BY MANY
WOMEN.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT TO DISCUSS
AND WILL BE DISCUSSED.
NO SINGLE MOMENT I THINK WILL
BREAK THROUGH AND BE THE MOMENT
OF THE DEBATE, BUT CERTAINLY A
LOT OF BACK-AND-FORTH THAT WILL
BE MEMORABLE.
JOHN, YOUR THOUGHTS?
JOHN: I AGREE WITH MOST OF WHAT
YOU SAID, BUT I THINK ONE MOMENT
WILL STAND OUT TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY IN THE
CONTEXT OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD FOR
THE LAST WEEK IN WHICH DONALD
TRUMP HAS BEEN REPEATEDLY
TALKING ABOUT A RIGGED ELECTION,
SAYING THAT THE ELECTION WAS
RIGGED AND IT COULD BE STOLEN
AND THAT WE NEED TO WATCH
CERTAIN POLLING PLACES, THE IDEA
THAT DONALD TRUMP, ASKED IF HE
WOULD ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION -- THAT WILL BE A
MOMENT THAT WE GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
>> YOU ARE CORRECT.
AND IT SHOULD.
IT WILL BE, FROM THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN MANAGER POINT OF YOU,
KIND OF AN UNFORCED ERROR.
HE HAD MANY GOOD MOMENTS.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS -- I WILL NOT
SAY FLAWLESS, BUT SHE KEPT HIM
FROM WINNING THE DEBATE SIBLEY
BY BEING SO STRONG, BUT THE
MOMENT YOU HIGHLIGHTED, WHICH
FOR SOME REASON BLANK OUT OF MY
MIND FOR SOME MOMENT, REALLY
WILL BE THE MOMENT.
YOU SEE DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
FAMILY.
THAT MOMENT BECAUSE IT IS A
CONFLICT WITH HIS CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AND VICE PRESIDENT
NOMINEE.
JOHN: AND HIS WATER.
IT IS A CORE DEMOCRATIC NORM
THAT WE ACCEPT A PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER.
-- AND HIS DAUGHTER.
YOU CAN CALL FOR A RECOUNT, AS
AL GORE DID.
YOU CAN CHALLENGE RESULTS IN
COURTS, BUT IN THE END, THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION ARE THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION.
YOU ACCEPT THEM AND GRACIOUSLY
STEP ASIDE.
AS I SAID, HE WENT ON TO SAY
THAT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WERE ON
THE ROLLS ILLEGALLY.
THAT THERE WERE DEAD PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE VOTING.
IT WAS JUST THE CONTEXT OF THE
ANSWER AND THE BRUTE FACTOR THAT
I THINK WE'LL GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION, AGAIN, PARTICULARLY
IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS WEEK IN
WHICH HE HAS MADE RIGGED
ELECTIONS SO MUCH A PART OF HIS
RHETORIC.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT AROUND --
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
I THOUGHT THE FIRST 30 MINUTES,
HE WAS BETTER THAN HE HAS BEEN
IN ANY THREE OF THE DEBATES.
HE WAS CALM AND COMPOSED, BUT AS
THE DEBATE STARTED TO GET MORE
EMOTIONAL, HE STARTED TO GET
MORE EMOTIONAL, AND BY AND
LARGE, HE STARTED TO GET MORE
EMOTIONAL -- BIOLOGICAL, CLINTON
REMAINED STRONG -- BY AND LARGE,
CLINTON STAYED STRONG.
>> EVEN THE MOST HARD-CORE
SUPPORTERS, I'M NOT SURE THERE
IS EVEN A SUPPORT, CERTAINLY
WITHIN THE BROADER PARTY, WITHIN
THE ESTABLISHMENT, WITHIN THE
MEDIA, THAT IS A POSITION THAT
WILL RAISE A LOT OF CONCERN, AND
I SUSPECT TO THE EXTENT HE DOES
INTERVIEWS IN COMING DAYS, TO
THE EXTENT HIS CAMPAIGN FIELDS
QUESTIONS WHEN THEY WOULD LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT HIS STRONG MOMENTS
DURING THE DEBATE, MOSTLY WHAT
THEY WILL BE ASKED ABOUT IS WHAT
IS UP WITH HIS POSITION ON
ACCEPTING THE RESULTS ARE NOT.
JOHN: LET'S BE CLEAR -- HIS
CAMPAIGN THIS WEEK, HIS CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AND OTHERS TRIED
REPEATEDLY TO SAY THAT WHAT HE
IS REALLY TALKING ABOUT IS THE
MEDIA BIAS, THE PERCEPTION THAT
HE IS GETTING A RAW DEAL FROM
THE MEDIA, AND EVERY TIME THEY
TRY TO DO THAT, HE ON TWITTER
AND ELSEWHERE BROUGHT IT BACK TO
THE POSSIBILITY OF VOTER FRAUD,
WHICH AS WE KNOW THROUGH
ACADEMIC STUDIES AND OTHERWISE,
IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY RARE
OCCURRENCE IN THE UNITED STATES,
AS PEOPLE LIKE SCOTT WALKER AND
OTHER ELECTION OFFICIALS POINTED
OUT THIS WEEK.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO CALL IT
UNFORCED ERROR.
I THINK IT IS ACTUALLY WHAT HE
BELIEVES.
>> OBVIOUSLY, HE MUST HAVE BEEN
PREPARED DURING DEBATE PREP TO
TAKE THE QUESTION, BUT I'M NOT
CERTAIN -- AND SPECULATING HERE
-- I'M NOT CERTAIN THAT THE
ANSWERS HIS ADVISERS URGED HIM
TO GIVE.
JOHN: I'M CERTAIN THERE ARE MANY
ADVISERS AROUND HIM THAT WERE
HORRIFIED BY THE ANSWER.
I MENTION THERE WERE SOME WHO
HAVE BEEN CHEERING HIM ON, BUT
IT DOES SEEM TO ME TO BE WHAT HE
BELIEVES.
I THINK HE MAY VERY WELL HAVE
REJECTED HIS ADVISERS.
YOU HAD KELLYANNE CONWAY, HIS
DAUGHTER, OTHERS SAYING HE WILL
ACCEPT THE ELECTION RESULTS, AND
HERE HE IS SAYING IN FRONT OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
SOMETHING WE HAVE NEVER SEEN IN
OUR LIFETIMES OR LIFETIMES PRIOR
TO OUR LIFETIME IN A
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE EVER.
>> HILLARY CLINTON STILL IN THE
HALL SHAKING HANDS WITH
SUPPORTERS AND OTHERS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS CREATED A
PROBLEM IN TERMS OF HIS CAMPAIGN
GETTING OUT THEIR MESSAGE AND
PARTICULARLY FOR MIKE PENCE, WHO
IN A ROUND OF INTERVIEWS WITH
BLOOMBERG AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IMMEDIATELY MADE
IT CLEAR THAT OF COURSE THEY
WOULD ACCEPT RESULTS.
THERE WERE A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD MOVE ON TO.
DONALD TRUMP, MORE THAN HE HAS
IN ANY OTHER DEBATE, AND I THINK
HE IS BEING ROUNDLY HAILED FOR
HAVING LONG STRETCHES OF CALM,
ON MESSAGE PERFORMANCE, TALKED A
LOT ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON'S
RECORD AS PART OF THE WASHINGTON
ESTABLISHMENT, AND THOSE MOMENTS
VERY IN LINE WITH THE KELLYANNE
CONWAY WING OF HIS CAMPAIGN,
CAMPAIGN MANAGER WHO LIKE HIM TO
BE TALKING ABOUT CHANGE.
A MORE CENTRIST MESSAGE WHICH
COULD ACTUALLY PUT TOGETHER A
MAJORITY, POTENTIALLY.
JOHN: I WILL POINT OUT ON
TWITTER --
>> LEAVING THE DEBATE WHILE
HILLARY CLINTON STATES.
-- STAYS.
JOHN: "THE POST" POINTING OUT A
JUNCTURE BETWEEN HOW TRUMP TALKS
AND HOW CONWAY WOULD LIKE HIM TO
TALK, KELLYANNE CONWAY
RE-TWEETED THAT WITH AN ARROW,
SUGGESTING THAT SHE IS
SUPPORTING THIS VIEW.
SHE SEEMED TO PUBLICLY ENDORSE
THAT.
WE THEN SEE SOME REAL DISCORD
COMING INTO THE OPEN I THINK IN
THE DAYS AHEAD WITHIN TRUMP'S
WORLD.
I DON'T LIKE TO MAKE
PRODUCTIONS, BUT I THINK THERE
ARE A LOT OF SIGNS THAT WE MAY
SEE SOME REAL RAPTURES IN TRUMP
WORLD OVER THE DAYS AHEAD.
>> YOU SEE THE DEBATE HALL.
HILLARY CLINTON STILL THERE
SHAKING HANDS.
THE FINAL DEBATE OF THIS
CAMPAIGN FOR HER.
THE FINAL OF THREE DEBATES
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP HAS LEFT THE DEBATE
HALL.
THE ROOM WE ARE IN, THE SPIN
ROOM, FILLING UP WITH ADVISERS
FOR BOTH CAMPAIGNS, WHO COME
HERE TO TELL THE MEDIA WHAT THEY
THOUGHT OF THE DEBATE.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE ANALYSIS
HERE.
YOU ARE WATCHING "BLOOMBERG
POLITICS," LIVE COVERAGE AFTER
THE DEBATE ARE JOHN HEILEMANN
AND I AND OUR COLLEAGUES WILL BE
BACK WITH ANALYSIS, GUESTS FROM
BOTH CAMPAIGNS, AND MORE.
JOHN: AND THE MOST TWEETED
MOMENTS.
>> BLOOMBERG TELEVISION AND
TWITTER RIGHT AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: WELCOME BACK.
MARK HALPERIN AND ME IN THE SPIN
ROOM.
WE ARE JOINED BY GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN, BIG SUPPORTER OF DONALD
TRUMP.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT WHAT
WILL OBVIOUSLY BE THE BIGGEST
HEADLINE OUT OF THIS DEBATE,
DONALD TRUMP SAYING ON STAGE
THAT HE WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION.
HIS CAMPAIGN MANAGER ON CNN HAS
COME OUT AND THAT NO, DONALD
TRUMP WILL ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION.
WHAT SAY YOU?
NO PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE HAS EVER
SAID ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WILL HE OR WILL HE NOT ACCEPT
THE RESULTS OF THE ELECTION?
>> I THINK HE WILL ACCEPT THE
RESULTS, AND A THINK WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT IS WE JUST HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR ELECTIONS ARE
RUN PROPERLY AND THAT THEY ARE
DONE CORRECTLY AND THAT WE FEEL
AS AMERICANS THAT EVERYTHING
THAT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO DO
DURING THESE ELECTIONS ARE DONE
IN THE WAY WE HAVE ALWAYS DONE
OUR NATIONAL ELECTIONS.
WHEREVER THE OUTCOME IS, HE WILL
ACCEPT THAT OUTCOME.
JOHN: YOU REALIZE YOUR POSITION
IS DIFFERENT FROM HIS?
IT'S NOT DIFFERENT.
IT'S WHAT HE SAID.
PART OF THIS, ALSO, TOO, AND HE
TALKED ABOUT IT, WAS LOOK AT
JUST THE BARRAGE OF ABUSE HE HAS
GOTTEN FROM THE MEDIA.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE HAS HAD
TO PUT UP WITH, WITHSTAND --
JUST IN THE LAST WEEK ALONE IF
NOT THE LAST THREE OR FOUR
MONTHS.
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT WHAT IS
GOING ON IN OUR ELECTION
PROCESS, WHEN YOU HAVE SORT OF
THIS COLUMN, WHICH IS WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT, WHEN YOU
HAVE THE MEDIA GOING AFTER JUST
ONE CANDIDATE -- I MEAN, IT'S
ALMOST 95% OF THE MEDIA AROUND
THIS COUNTRY THAT IS JUST
ATTACKING DONALD TRUMP ON A
CONSTANT BASIS -- THAT POISONS
THE MIND OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
INTO THINKING THAT, "GEEZ, IS
THIS GUY THAT BAD"
JOHN: I'M SURE YOU DID NOT MEAN
TO SUGGEST THAT THE PRESS IN
THIS COUNTRY ARE LIKE NAZI
COLLABORATORS, RIGHT?
>> I WOULD SUGGEST THE PRESS HAS
A MASSIVE BIAS AGAINST TRUMP.
MARK: DID HE SAY IT EXACTLY THE
WAY HE SHOULD HAVE SAID IT?
>> I THINK WHAT HE SAID WAS
ESSENTIALLY THAT -- WE JUST HAVE
TO WAIT TO SEE WHAT THE OUTCOME
IS.
HOW THE ELECTION PROCESS GOES.
THE OUTCOME OF IT, WHATEVER THE
OUTCOME OF IT IS, WE WILL HAVE A
PEACEFUL ELECTION AND ALL THAT
SORT OF STUFF, AND HE WILL
ACCEPT WHATEVER THE OUTCOME IS.
I WOULD NOT READ MUCH MORE INTO
IT.
BUT BACK TO THE RIGGED SYSTEM
THAT HE HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT,
PART OF THIS IS THE MEDIA.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY THE MEDIA.
YOU CANNOT STAND HERE AND -- YOU
KNOW, YOUR LISTENERS AND
LISTENERS IN ALL MEDIA -- YOU
CANNOT STAND HERE AND SAY
THERE'S NOT A BIAS IN THE MEDIA
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
MARK: WAS THERE MEDIA BIAS
AGAINST HIM WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
FOR THE NOMINATION?
>> DURING THE PRIMARIES?
I DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK.
MARK: DO YOU ACCEPT THAT JOHN
PODESTA'S E-MAILS WERE HACKED BY
RUSSIA?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST KNOW WHAT I HAVE READ IN
THE MEDIA.
MARK: YOU HAVE NOT BEEN BRIEFED
ON THAT?
ARE NOT SURE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE NOT BEEN BRIEFED ON THAT.
IF IT'S RUSSIA, IF IT'S A
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION, WHAT I
KNOW IS WHAT I'VE READ IN THE
MEDIA.
MARK: WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THE
WIKILEAKS DOCUMENTS?
>> THE WHOLE ISSUE ABOUT RUSSIA,
WHAT ABOUT THE CONTENT OF THE
E-MAILS?
MARK: THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING YOU
ABOUT, THE CONTENT.
WHAT IS IN THOSE E-MAILS THAT
WAS DISCUSSED TONIGHT?
>> I WISH MORE WAS DISCUSSED.
>> WHAT DID NOT COME UP?
>> I JUST WISH THE DISPARAGING
COMMENTS ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN DATED BY
HILLARY CLINTON IN HER E-MAILS
AND JOHN PODESTA IN HIS E-MAILS
AND JUST THE EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION --
>> THEY ARE NOT HER E-MAILS.
THEY ARE E-MAILS OF PEOPLE WHO
WORK OR HER.
>> OK, IS THAT THE CLIMATE THAT
SHE HAS AROUND HER?
I WISH THAT THERE WAS MORE
TALKED ABOUT WITH -- IT IS A
CONTENT OF THE INFORMATION.
I GOT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN HACKED
AND ALL THAT.
I GOT ALL THAT.
THAT HAPPENED, AND IT IS A
CRIMINAL ACT OR AN ACT OF
TERRORISM, HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
DESCRIBE IT, BUT THE CONTENT OF
THE INFORMATION IS REALLY WHAT
IS ALSO AN ISSUE, AND SHOULD BE
BROUGHT OUT, AND I THINK THE
OTHER THING, TOO, IS THE ISSUE
ABOUT THE 33,000 E-MAILS, THE
NUMBERS OF THINGS THAT SHE HAS
SAID THAT TURNED OUT TO BE LIES.
YOU CANNOT DENY THAT.
JOHN: I WANT TO CLARIFY ONE
THING -- YOU ARE ONE OF DONALD
TRUMP OFF TOP NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISERS, RIGHT?
HE HAS RECEIVED INTELLIGENCE
BRIEFINGS, RIGHT?
AS THE NOMINEE?
>> HE HAS RECEIVED A COUPLE.
JOHN: IT IS THE CONTENTION OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE HE HAS BEEN
BRIEFED ON THIS ISSUE.
>> HE HAS NOT BEEN BRIEFED ON
THIS ISSUE.
OF WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
THIS BUSINESS ABOUT WHO HAS DONE
WHAT, NO.
JOHN: THANK YOU --
>> WHAT WE HAVE IS WHAT WE SEE
IN THE MEDIA.
JOHN: JUST WANTED TO CLEAR THAT
UP.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
APPRECIATE THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO THROW OUT TO OUR
COLLEAGUE, MEGAN MURPHY, SO SHE
CAN GIVE US HER THOUGHTS ON WHAT
HAPPENED TONIGHT AND ARE A
COUPLE OF INFORMAL INTERVIEWS.
MEGAN: THANKS, JOHN.
ALL NIGHT, OUR PARTNERS AT
TWITTER HAVE BEEN MAPPING THE
TOP-TWEETED MOMENTS OF THE NIGHT
AND WE HAVE THEM RIGHT NOW.
TONIGHT, THE MOMENT THAT GOT THE
MOST TWEETS CAME AROUND 9:57
EASTERN WHEN HILLARY CLINTON
WENT AFTER DONALD TRUMP'S PAST
TREATMENT OF WOMEN.
TAKE A LOOK AND A LISTEN.
SECRETARY CLINTON: HE HELD A
NUMBER OF BIG RALLIES WHERE HE
SAID THAT HE COULD NOT POSSIBLY
HAVE DONE THOSE THINGS TO THOSE
WOMEN BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
ATTRACTIVE ENOUGH FOR HIM -- TO
BE A SALTED.
MR. TRUMP: I DID NOT SAY THAT.
MEGAN: ANOTHER TOP TWEETED
MOMENT OF THE DEBATE WHEN DONALD
TRUMP AND HILLARY CLINTON HAD AN
EXCHANGE ABOUT ALEPPO AND TRUMP
DEFENDING HIS STATEMENT ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON IN SYRIA AND
ALSO WHEN TRUMP GAVE HIS MUCH
AWAITED WAIT-AND-SEE ANSWER ON
IF HE WOULD ACCEPT THE OUTCOME
OF THE ELECTION, TELLING US HE
WOULD KEEP US IN THE SPINS.
HIS RUNNING MATE GAVE A PRETTY
DIFFERENT ANSWER ON THAT
QUESTION, IN AN INTERVIEW JUST
MOMENTS BEFORE THE INTERVIEW
BEGAN.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> DONALD TRUMP MADE IT CLEAR IN
HIS FIRST DEBATE AND I HAVE MADE
IT CLEAR THAT WE WILL ACCEPT THE
WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, BUT
I THINK DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO
WIN.
WE HAVE A BRAND-NEW POLL OUT
FROM INVESTORS BUSINESS DAILY
THAT HAS US UP IN PERCENTAGE
POINT.
I SEE TREMENDOUS MOMENTUM ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> LET'S PUT UP A LINE GRAPH OF
TWITTER THROUGHOUT THE DEBATE.
THE HIGHEST PEAK OF TWITTER
TRAFFIC WAS ABOUT THE WOMEN
DISCUSSION CLIP WE JUST SAW.
MEANWHILE, THE TOP THREE ISSUES
TWITTER USES DISCUSSED WERE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS, THE ECONOMY,
AND REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS.
I'M JOINED NOW BY A BLOOMBERG
POLITICS REPORTER.
THE BIG TAKE AWAY MOMENT IS
GOING TO BE DONALD TRUMP SAYING
HE WOULD NOT CLARIFY IF YOU
WOULD ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION.
HE SAID IT NOT ONCE BUT TWICE.
HE SAID HE WOULD KEEP US IN
SUSPENSE AND HILLARY CLINTON
CALLING IT AN EFFECT HORRIFYING,
SAYING THAT IT WAS A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY, CHRIS WALLACE
REMINDING US AT THE END OF THE
EVENING HOW IMPORTANT EACH OF
OUR VOTES ARE.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS DAMAGING
FOR THE CANDIDACY AND WITHERING
UP CONCERN OVER SOMETHING
AMERICAN VOTES WILL SEE AS
FUNDAMENTAL, WHICH IS INTEGRITY
FOR OUR VOTING SYSTEM?
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN SAYING
THIS FOR A LONG TIME ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
IT IS A LITTLE TOO SOON TO SEE
IF THIS WILL AFFECT HIM, THIS
PARTICULAR STATEMENT.
BUT HE HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A WILD.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM RALLY HIS BASE
BEFORE.
ONE THING TO TAKE AWAY FROM THIS
NIGHT IS NEITHER CANDIDATE
REALLY MADE THEIR CASE ABOUT WHY
THEY SHOULD BE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT.
HILLARY DID MORE THAN DONALD
TRUMP, BUT IT WAS MUCH MORE
ABOUT WHY THE OTHER PERSON
SHOULD NOT BE PRESIDENT.
IT WAS LIKE A PIVOT CONTEST
WHERE THEY WOULD BE A QUESTION
AND ONE PERSON WOULD PICK IT TO
AN ATTACK AND THE NEXT PERSON
WOULD TAKE THAT ATTACK AND GIVE
IT TO A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SUBJECT -- PIVOT TO A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SUBJECT.
ONE OF THE MOMENTS HILLARY
CLINTON WAS THE STRONGEST WAS ON
THAT WHEN AN, PARTIALLY BECAUSE
SHE ATTACKED DONALD TRUMP, BUT
DID SHE PIVOTED AND SAID THAT WE
ARE BETTER THAN THIS AND GAVE
THIS LONG SPEECH ABOUT HOW THE
COUNTRY NEEDS TO STAND UP
BECAUSE THEY WERE BETTER THAN
THIS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS HER STRONGEST
MOMENT OF THE NIGHT.
SHE KEPT A VISION AND WAS NOT
JUST ATTACKING TRUMP.
MEGAN: SHE WAS MORE RILED, MORE
PERSONAL.
HER TEAM AND HERSELF DECIDED TO
TAKE ON AN EMOTIONAL ISSUE.
MARK HALPERIN AND JOHN HEILEMANN
HAVE HILLARY CLINTON'S POLLSTER
WITH THEM RIGHT NOW IN THE SPIN
ROOM.
JOHN: THANK YOU.
WE ARE HERE WITH THE STRATEGIST
FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
GETTING THE MOST ATTENTION,
DONALD TRUMP SAYING HE WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY ACCEPT THE RESULTS
OF THE ELECTION, AND HIS AIDES
SORT OF WALKING THAT BACK A
LITTLE BIT.
IS IT OK FOR HIM TO SAY LET'S
SEE WHAT HAPPENS?
>> NO, IT'S NOT OK.
I THINK WE HAVE THE REASON WHY
THE REST OF THE WORLD LOOKS TO
US IS THE GREATEST DEMOCRACY IN
THE WORLD.
WE HAVE HAD ORDERLY TRANSITIONS
AFTER EVERY PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
REPUBLICANS AROUND THE COUNTRY
ARE APPALLED BY WHAT HE IS
SAYING, BUT THEY'VE BEEN
APPALLED BY AN LOT IN HIS
CAMPAIGN.
TONIGHT WAS THE CLEAREST WIN OF
THE THREE.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON HAS WON
ALL THREE DEBATES.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS THE MOST
LOPSIDED.
JIM SAYING HE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IS JUST OUTRAGEOUS.
JOHN: WILL THAT HURT HIM WITH
VOTERS, AND IF SO, WHY?
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THIS
IS THE GREATEST DEMOCRACY IN
HISTORY.
THIS IS NOT A MYSTERY TO THEM.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR US TO
GO TO WAR WITH EACH OTHER, AND I
MEAN THAT METAPHORICALLY,
PLEASE.
FOR VOTERS, THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I HAVE EXPERIENCED VOTING,
WINNING, THE ON THE WINNING
SIDE, BEING ON THE LOSING SIDE.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT DEMOCRACY
WHEN IT WORKS AT ITS BEST AS WE
PICK UP THE PIECES, GO TO WORK
TOGETHER.
I THINK THAT IS WHY THIS WAS SO
LOPSIDED.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON TONIGHT
WAS THE ONLY PERSON ON THAT
STAGE WHO LAID OUT A VISION OF
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY SHE THINKS
WE ARE AND WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY
WE WANT TO BE AND WE ARE A SHARP
CONTRAST OF THE VALUES SIDE OF
THE ARGUMENT, THE ECONOMICS SIDE
AND HOW WE KEEP THE COUNTRY
SAFE.
JOHN: IN THE FIRST DATE, DONALD
TRUMP CAME OUT VERY STRONG THE
FIRST HALF HOUR AND SORT OF
UNRIVALED.
TONIGHT, I THINK HE CAME OUT
VERY CALM IN THE FIRST 30
MINUTES.
HE HAS A DIFFERENT LOOK THAN ANY
DONALD TRUMP WE HAVE SEEN OVER
THE LAST THREE DEBATES.
THAT LAST HOUR WAS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT, BUT TALK ABOUT THAT
FIRST HOUR.
WAS THAT A DONALD TRUMP YOU
EXPECTED TO SEE THE FIRST 30
MINUTES OR SO?
>> I'M IN THE MINORITY ON ALL OF
THIS.
I EXPECTED TO SEE THAT IN ALL
THREE.
WHAT HAS NOT TOTALLY SURPRISED
ME WITH THE THIRD IS HE CANNOT
DO THIS FOR 90 MINUTES.
HE BECOMES UNHINGED AT SOME
POINT, DURING WHICH HE ONLY HAS
TO TALK ABOUT 40 MINUTES -- HE
BECOMES UNHINGED AT SOME POINT
DURING A 90-MINUTE DEBATE,
DURING WHICH HE ONLY HAS TO TALK
ABOUT 40 MINUTES.
DURING THE FIRST 30 MINUTES, I
THOUGHT HE WAS TRYING TO KEEP IT
VERY COOL, STAY VERY CALM.
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT IN PARTICULAR
SET HIM OFF, BUT WE KNOW IT DOES
NOT TAKE MUCH IN PARTICULAR TO
SET HIM OFF AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS HE SHOULD NOT BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
JOHN: WE KNEW TRUMP WAS GOING TO
GO AFTER HER ON THE QUESTION OF
OPEN BORDERS.
HE DID.
FIRST TIME WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
IMMIGRATION IN ANY OF THE
DEBATES.
HOW DID YOU THINK THAT EXCHANGE
PLAYED LACQUA
>> I THINK HE HAS TALKED ABOUT
IMMIGRATION BEFORE.
CERTAINLY TALKED ABOUT BUILDING
A WALL.
IT WAS NOT AS FULL A SECTION --
JOHN: THAT'S WHAT I MEANT.
>> AMERICANS KNOW WE ARE A
NATION OF IMMIGRANTS.
MY GRANDPARENTS CAME FROM
ANOTHER COUNTRY.
I AM OBVIOUSLY NOT A RECENT
YOUNG PERSON HERE.
I HAVE BEEN HERE FOR A FEW
DECADES.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE KNOW WE CAME
FROM DIFFERENT PLACES AND ONE OF
THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT AMERICA
IS THAT WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE IT WORK FOR OURSELVES.
ISN'T ALWAYS EASY?
OF COURSE NOT AND I DON'T THINK
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD SAY IT IS
ALWAYS EASY.
WHEN YOU START PITTING PEOPLE
AGAINST EACH OTHER AND START
CALLING OUT AN AMERICAN JUDGE
BECAUSE OF HIS MEXICAN HERITAGE,
THAT IS DIVISIVE AND NOT JUST
DIVISIVE, BUT MOST VOTERS RECOIL
AT THAT.
JOHN: I THINK THE CHARGE IS SHE
HAS A MUCH MORE LIBERAL ATTITUDE
TOWARDS LIBERATION -- TOWARDS
IMMIGRATION THEN WHEN SHE EVEN
ESPOUSES IN DEBATES.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THE
ACCUSATION THAT HILLARY WAS A
MUCH MORE LIBERAL IMMIGRATION IS
THE MAN SHE IS WILLING TO ADMIT?
>> SHE FULLY ESPOUSES
IMMIGRATION REFORM, AS
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS HAVE
FOR SEVERAL DECADES.
WE HAVE TO DO THINGS TO SECURE
OUR BORDER.
WE HAVE TO CREATE A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS -- UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE BEEN LIVING
HERE, WORKING HERE, PAYING THE
TAXES, HAVE A PERIOD THROUGH
WHICH THEY CAN GO THROUGH A PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP.
NOT BREAK UP FAMILIES, NOT SEND
PEOPLE BACK WHO HAVE BEEN LIVING
HERE.
ONE OF THE GREAT MOMENTS IN THE
DEBATE WAS WHEN SHE POINTED OUT
THAT THERE ARE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE PAYING MORE
IN FEDERAL INCOME TAXES THAN
DONALD TRUMP IS, INCLUDING MONEY
SOME OF WHICH GOES FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
MARK: WHEN WIKILEAKS CAME UP,
SHE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS HACKING INTO JOHN
PODESTA PLUS E-MAILS.
TRUMP WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONTENT.
DO YOU THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT THE RUSSIAN ANGLE
MORE THAN THE CONTENT OR BOTH?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
CARE MOST ABOUT THEIR OWN LIVES.
I THINK THEY CARE ABOUT THE FACT
THAT RUSSIA MIGHT BE MEDDLING IN
ELECTIONS.
THE RELATED PEAS WHICH I THINK
SHE DROVE HOME PRETTY WELL IS
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE DONALD
TRUMP, WHO DOES NOT TO BELIEVE
WHAT 17 INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IN
THIS COUNTRY HAVE SAID.
HE WANTS TO BELIEVE RUSSIA.
THAT IS JUST UNHEARD OF.
MARK: AS WE GO FORWARD, YOU ALL
ARE FEELING PRETTY GOOD.
IS THERE FEAR OR CONCERNED THERE
COULD BE MORE WIKILEAKS
DISCLOSURES BETWEEN NOW AND
ELECTION DAY?
>> I ALWAYS SAY THIS ELECTION IS
ABOUT THEIR LIVES FIRST AND
FOREMOST IN THE FUTURE, AS
PRESIDENT CLINTON ONCE SAID, NOT
THE PAST.
VOTERS HEARD TONIGHT ONE
CANDIDATE DURING THE COURSE OF
THAT DEBATE WHO HAS TALKED ABOUT
THEIR LIVES, THAT WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT THEY WILL
BE FOCUSED ON IF THEY HAVE NOT
MADE UP THEIR MINDS.
WE ARE SEEING A SHRINKING POOL
OF PEOPLE OPEN TO THIS, AND FOR
DONALD TRUMP, THE CHALLENGE IS
IN NONE OF THESE THREE DEBATES
HAS HE REACHED OUT BEYOND HIS
BASE.
HE JUST DOES NOT DO IT.
HILLARY CLINTON SAID IT TONIGHT
-- "I'M GOING TO BE A PRESIDENT
FOR ALL AMERICANS."
MARK: THANK YOU.
WE ARE HERE IN THE SPIN ROOM AND
WILL BE BACK WITH MORE OF OUR
LIFE POSTDEBATE COVERAGE RIGHT
AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: WELCOME BACK.
WE ARE WRAPPING UP TONIGHT'S
BLOOMBERG POLITICS/TWITTER
COVERAGE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEVADA LAS VEGAS.
MARK: HILLARY CLINTON BILL
CLINTON FINALLY LEAVING THE
DEBATE SITE.
THE CLINTON TEAM FEELING GOOD,
AND IT'S HARD TO FAULT HER
PERFORMANCE.
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN MOMENTS
WHERE SHE WAS A FACE IT, BUT SHE
WAS EVASIVE IN A DEFT WAY AND
WAS PRETTY GOOD AT TURNING
THINGS AWAY.
THERE WILL BE MAYBE HALF A DOZEN
OR MORE TOPICS WITH PUBLICANS
WILL SAY SHE DID NOT ADDRESS THE
QUESTION.
JOHN: I WOULD LIKE TO RETURN
BRIEFLY TO OUR INTERVIEW WITH
MICHAEL FLYNN, WHO I FOUND
PERFECTLY REFLECTIVE OF THE
CONFUSION RIGHT NOW THE TRUNK
CAMPAIGN ABOUT WHAT TO SAY ABOUT
WHAT DONALD TRUMP SAID ON STAGE.
I CANNOT FIGURE OUT WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
ON THE ONE HAND, HE SAID THEY
WOULD ACCEPT THE RESULTS, I
THOUGHT HE WAS INTELLECTUALLY
SOMEWHAT INCOHERENT.
MARK: WE HAVE HEARD FROM A RANGE
OF REPUBLICANS HERE IN THE SPIN
ROOM.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE RNC,
BASICALLY SAYING THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO WIN, SO IT WILL NOT BE
A PROBLEM OR SAYING THEY WILL
ACCEPT THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE OR
LET'S THE WHAT HAPPENS, BUT THEY
ARE ALL TAKING A LESS HARD-LINE
POSITION BUT TRYING NOT TO HER
PEW DE EIGHT WHEN HE SAID
BECAUSE THAT IS A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
JOHN: BUT AGAIN, IT LEAVES OPEN
THE QUESTION WE RAISED EARLIER,
WHICH IS WHAT DOES DONALD TRUMP
ACTUALLY THINK ABOUT THIS, AND I
THINK HE HAS MADE HIMSELF CLEAR
-- HE THINKS THE ELECTION IS
RIGGED AND HE'S NOT READY TO SAY
THAT HE HAS A IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS AND WILL ACCEPT THE
OUTCOME.
THE QUESTION IS -- WHAT HAPPENS
TOMORROW AND THE DAY AFTER
TOMORROW?
THIS QUESTION WILL BE BACK AND
RAISED REPEATEDLY.
MARK: MORE SPINNING GOING ON IN
THE NEWSROOM BY DONALD TRUMP
JUNIOR AND ERIC TRUMP HERE IN
THE SPIN ROOM, BUT LET'S GO BACK
OUTSIDE TO OUR WASHINGTON BUREAU
CHIEF, AND THEY CAN MURPHY, FOR
HER THOUGHTS.
MEGAN: THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THIS MOMENT OF HIM SAYING HE IS
GOING TO KEEP US IN SUSPENSE
ABOUT IF HE WILL ACCEPT RESULTS
AND ALSO HIS COMMENTS ABOUT
WOMEN WHO ACCUSED 10 OF UNWANTED
SEXUAL ADVANCES, THAT THEY WANT
FAME AND ARE PART OF THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, BUT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ANOTHER MOMENT THAT
WAS A FAIRLY EXTRAORDINARY
EXCHANGE ABOUT RUSSIA THAT WILL
GET A BUNCH OF ATTENTION IN
EUROPE AND WITH OUR ALLIES
ABROAD AND HIS AGAIN EMBRACING
PUTIN, WHILE SAYING HE DOES NOT
KNOW HIM, SAYING HE IS A STRONG
LEADER AND HILLARY CLINTON
ACCUSING HIM OF THE INCLUDING'S
PUPPET.
IT WAS A PROFOUND CLASH IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY, AND AGAIN, DONALD TRUMP
WITH THIS VERY EXTRAORDINARY
INABILITY TO DISTANCE HIMSELF
FROM A REGIME THAT ALMOST ACROSS
HIS ENTIRE PARTY INCLUDING HIS
RUNNING MATE, REPEATEDLY
DENOUNCING COULDN'T'S STRATEGY,
POLICIES, ETC.
IN TERMS OF WIDER GLOBAL IMPACT
OF THIS DEBATE, THAT WILL BE
ANOTHER MOMENT PEOPLE WILL PICK
OUT AND EXAMINED OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS.
JOHN: I HAD TO QUIT QUESTIONS.
WHERE YOU THINK THINGS STAND NOW
WITH THE RELATION TO WIKILEAKS
HEADING OUT OF THIS DEBATE?
MARK: I THINK THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
IS GOING TO SAY OVER AND OVER
WHO REALLY CARES WHAT THEY CAME
FROM -- WHERE THEY CAME FROM?
THERE IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN.
LET'S FOCUS ON THE CONTENT.
I'VE ASKED WHAT DOCUMENTS THEY
WANT PEOPLE TO FOCUS ON.
THERE IS STILL A LOT, BUT
NOTHING THAT CLEARLY BREAKS
THROUGH.
JOHN: NOT FOCUSING ON ONE OR TWO
TO KEY DOCUMENTS THAT PROVE
SOMETHING REALLY DAMNING.
THE SECOND THING I HAVE IS ON
THE QUESTION OF DONALD TRUMP IN
THE WOMEN WHO ACCUSED HIM, HE
DISMISSED THEN OUT OF HAND AND
BASICALLY SAID ALL OF THEM ARE
LYING.
MARK: AND WHEN EVEN FURTHER
SAYING THIS WAS DONE BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
JOHN: WHERE DO YOU FEEL THAT
ISSUE STANDS AS WE HEAD INTO THE
LAST 2.5 WEEKS OF THE ELECTION.
MARK: NO WOMEN HAVE COME FORWARD
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
IF THERE ARE NO MORE, YOU WILL
NOT SEE MUCH NEWS COVERAGE OFF
OF IT.
WITH A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, AND A
LOT OF THE COVERAGE WILL BE
ABOUT POLLS AND WITH THE
CANDIDATES ARE SPENDING MONEY,
IF DONALD TRUMP STILL HAS A
PASSAGE -- A PATH TO THE
ELECTORATE.
JOHN: IF TRUMP REMAINS CLOSE TO
DOUBLE DIGITS BEHIND HILLARY
CLINTON.
MARK: IT TAKES IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND ENORMOUS
CONTROVERSY TO BREAK THROUGH AND
BECOME THE KIND OF ENORMOUS
STORY WE SAW A FEW DAYS AGO WITH
THE RELEASE OF THE "EXCESS
HOLLYWOOD" TAPE.
JOHN: I DO NOT ANTICIPATE IT
WILL BE A PRETTY ONE HALF WEEKS,
BUT MORE CRAWLING AROUND IN THE
MUD, BUT I THINK WE ARE NOW
FINALLY AT THIS MOMENT HEADED
INTO THE GENUINE HOMESTRETCH,
WHICH IS BOTH EXCITING AND A BIT
OF A RELIEF.
FOR MARK HALPERIN AND ME HERE IN
THE SPIN ROOM AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF NEVADA LAS VEGAS, WE WANT TO
THANK OUR FRIENDS AT TWITTER WHO
HAVE BEEN OUR EXCLUSIVE ARTIST
FOR THIS AND ALL THE OTHER
DEBATE NIGHT COVERAGE WE HAVE
DONE.
BE SURE TO TUNE INTO OUR SHOW,
"WITH ALL DUE RESPECT," LIVE AT
5:00 P.M. EASTERN AND ON TWITTER
WHERE WE STREAM LIVE EVERY DAY.
UNTIL TOMORROW, WE SAY TO YOU,
SAYONARA.
♪
QUOTE -- ANGIE: WELCOME TO
BLOOMBERG MARKETS ASIA.
LET'S GET TO OUR TOP STORY RIGHT
NOW, THE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE THE
JUST ENDED LITTLE OVER HALF AN
HOUR AGO.
DONALD TRUMP ONCE AGAIN REFUSED
TO SAY THAT HE WILL ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION IF HE
LOSES, IN THAT SAYING HE IS
GOING TO KEEP THE PUBLIC IN
SUSPENSE.
FOR HER PART, CLINTON CALLED HIS
STATEMENT HORRIFYING.
TRUMP ALSO SAID THAT CLINTON,
HER HUSBAND BILL CLINTON, WHEN
HE WAS PRESIDENT, SIGNED A BAD
DEAL AND THAT HE WOULD
RENEGOTIATE NAFTA.
TAKE A LISTEN.
MR. TRUMP: I AM GOING TO
RENEGOTIATE NAFTA, AND IF I
CANNOT MAKE A GREAT DEAL, WE'RE
GOING TO TERMINATE NAFTA AND
CREATE GREAT DEALS.
WE ARE GOING TO TERMINATE IT.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE A GREAT
TRADE DEAL, AND IF WE CANNOT, WE
ARE GOING TO GO A SEPARATE WAY
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
DAVID: HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
PREVIOUS JOBS REPORT, HOW BAD IT
WAS, AND THAT IF HE WAS ELECTED,
HE WOULD TAKE GROWTH FROM 1% OR
CLOSER TO ZERO NOW, HE SAID, TO
4%, 5%.
HE COMPARED U.S. GROWTH TO
CHINA.
HE BASICALLY WANTS TO GET THE
GROWTH ENGINE GOING.
FOR HER PART, HILLARY CLINTON,
OF COURSE, ALSO TALKING ABOUT
HOW THE POLICIES THAT PERHAPS
MR. TRUMP, IF ELECTED, WOULD BE
PUTTING IN PLACE WOULD ACTUALLY
LEAD THE U.S. INTO A RECESSION.
HAVE A LISTEN.
SECRETARY CLINTON: HIS WHOLE
PLAN IS TO CUT TAXES, TO GIVE
THE BIGGEST TAX BREAKS EVER TO
THE WEALTHY AND TO CORPORATIONS,
ADDING $20 TRILLION TO OUR DEBT
AND CAUSING THE KIND OF
DISLOCATION WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE
BECAUSE IT TRULY WILL BE
TRICKLE-DOWN ECONOMICS ON
STEROIDS.
THE PLAN I HAVE I THINK WILL
ACTUALLY PRODUCE GREATER
OPPORTUNITY.
THE PLAN HE HAS WILL COST US
JOBS AND POSSIBLY LEAD TO
ANOTHER GREAT RECESSION.
ENTRY: NOTABLE IN THIS PART OF
THE WORLD, CLINTON ALSO CALLED
OUT TRUMP FOR HIS DEFENSE POLICY
IN WHICH HE SAID THAT JAPAN AND
SAUDI ARABIA AND A LOT OF OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE SOUTH KOREA HAVE
NOT BEEN PAYING THEIR WAY.
CLINTON SAID THAT AMERICA NEEDS
TO MAINTAIN THOSE STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS.
DEFINITELY A POLICY DIFFERENCE.
DAVID: THIS TIME AROUND, THERE
WAS A LOT MORE DISCUSSED WHEN IT
COMES TO POLICY.
THEY ENDED ON HOW DEEP IN DEBT
THE U.S. IS.
IN ANY CASE, IT IS TIME TO LOOK
AT HOW MARKETS ARE DOING ACROSS
THE REGION AS WE MAKE OUR WAY
OUT OF THE DEBATE.
LET'S GET STARTED HERE.
THERE WE GO, JAPAN, WHICH IS
ABOUT 15 MINUTES SHORT OF
GETTING OUT OF ITS LUNCH BREAK
RIGHT NOW.
THEY WOULD GO, 1%.
STOCKS ACROSS THE ASIAN PACIFIC
-- THE ASIA-PACIFIC, NO BIG
MOVES.
A LITTLE BIT OF WEAKNESS COMING
THROUGH IN THE JAPANESE YEN.
LET'S HAVE A LOOK AT WHAT ELSE
WE ARE SEEING ACROSS THE REGION.
THERE WE GO.
BY THE WAY, INFLATION COMING UP
A LITTLE BIT LATER ON.
CNH MARKETS SEEING A LITTLE BIT
OF WEAKNESS AS WELL, SO I THINK
WE ARE SEEING A LITTLE BIT OF
DOLLAR STRENGTH COME THROUGH.
NOT A LOT.
YOU WOULD EXPECT A LITTLE BIT OF
A BOUNCE.
WHAT ELSE ARE WE LOOKING AT?
THE JOBS NUMBER OUT, WHICH IS
WHY, I GUESS, WE ARE SEEING THIS
OUTSIZE MOVE RELATIVELY SPEAKING
IN THE AUSSIE DOLLAR.
STILL SEEING SOME GAINS ON THE
ASX 200, BREAKING DOWN WHAT IS
LEADING THOSE GAINS.
YOU CAN SEE FINANCIALS, NOT
REALLY.
1.3%.
I JUST WANT TO SHOW THIS.
I HAVE IT HERE ON MY TERMINAL.
ANGIE: I WAS WAITING FOR YOU TO
SAY THIS.
DAVID: OF WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE DEBATE.
ANGIE: OFTEN SEEN AS A BAROMETER
FOR TRUMP.
HE SAID BUILD A WALL, AND WE
HAVE SEEN THIS AS THE MARKET
REACTION TO IF TRUMP WAS STRONG
OR WEAK.
DAVID: WHEN HE FIRST MENTIONED
THE WALL, WE SAW A SPIKE.
WE BASICALLY PUSHED DOWN ON THE
EXCHANGE RATE.
I THINK THIS TAKES US BACK TO
ABOUT A THREE-WEEK LOW.
WE WILL BE TALKING MORE ABOUT
THIS A BIT LATER ON, BUT --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE REALLY
FRONT AND CENTER AS WE GO BACK
TO OUR COVERAGE OF THE BARCLAYS
ASIA FORUM WHERE DELEGATES HAVE
NO DOUBT BEEN KEEPING AN EYE ON
THE DEBATE.
OUR SOUTHEAST ASIA CORRESPONDENT
IS WITH ONE OF THE MOST
PROMINENT COMMENTATORS ON THE
ECONOMY.
OVER TO YOU.
>> LIKE YOU SAID, FRONT AND
CENTER.
ALL EYES AND EARS ON THE U.S.
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
WE HAVE A HOHMAN EL-ERIAN
JOINING US THIS MORNING.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO BE -- FOR THERE TO BE A
CLEAR WINNER.
>> DEPENDS ON WHAT THE WINNER
IS.
I ONLY SAW THE FIRST HOUR OF THE
DEBATE, AND IT WAS NICE TO HAVE
A MORE CIVIL DEBATE AND AN
ACTUAL DISCUSSION OF POLICIES.
THE MARKET FEARS ONE OF TWO
OUTCOMES.
ONE, A CLEAR WIN BY DONALD TRUMP
THAT SUGGESTS NOT ONLY HE WILL
SECURE THE WHITE HOUSE BUT ALSO
THAT HE WOULD IMPLEMENT
IMMEDIATELY TERRORISTS ON CHINA
AND MEXICO.
THAT IS AN OUTCOME THAT THE
MARKET IS WORRIED ABOUT BECAUSE
IT WOULD MOST LIKELY LEAD TO
RECESSIONAL CONDITIONS.
THE OTHER OUTCOME THE MARKET IS
NOT COMFORTABLE WITH IS A CLEAN
SWEEP BY DEMOCRATS, THAT MR.
TRUMP LOSES SO BADLY AT THE
DEBATE THAT THAT CREATES
MOMENTUM NOT JUST FOR DEMOCRATS
TO WIN THE WHITE HOUSE BUT ALSO
TO SECURE BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS.
WHAT I SAW IN THE DEBATE THE
FIRST HOUR SUGGESTS NEITHER OF
THOSE THINGS HAPPEN, THAT IT WAS
NOT DECISIVE ENOUGH ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER, AND THEREFORE, I
SUSPECT MARKETS WILL TAKE THE
OUTCOME OF THIS DEBATE RATHER
CALMLY.
>> WHAT WOULD A TRUMP
PRESIDENTIAL MEAN -- PRESIDENCY
MEAN FOR ASIA?
>> IT DEPENDS IF A TRUMP
PRESIDENCY, IF IT WERE TO OCCUR,
WOULD IT BE FOLLOWED BY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL THE
ANTI-TRADE RHETORIC THAT HAS
BEEN PART OF THE CAMPAIGN?
IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN, IT WOULD
BE ANOTHER BLOW TO THE OPEN
GLOBAL SYSTEM THAT ASIA HAS
BOUGHT INTO.
ALREADY, WE SEE IT BEING
QUESTIONED BY VARIOUS
GOVERNMENTS, BUT THE U.S. AS A
MAJOR ECONOMY, SUDDENLY THE U.S.
GOES ANTI-TRADE, THAT WOULD BE A
BIG BLOW TO ASIA.
>> THE MARKET LOOKING AT THE
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE, BUT IT IS
ALSO LOOKING AT THE MOVEMENT BY
THE FED.
TO WHAT EXTENT WILL JANET YELLEN
TAKE THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
INTO CONSIDERATION BEFORE MAKING
A MOVE.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY LOOK AT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS AS MUCH
AS THEY LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO CONFIDENCE, TO
SENTIMENT.
I DO THINK THAT THE FED IS
APOLITICAL.
THAT THEY TRIED TO SEE THROUGH
SHORT-TERM POLITICAL EVENTS, AND
WHAT THEY WILL BE LOOKING AT IN
DECEMBER IN THEIR FIRST MEETING
AFTER WORD IS THE DOMESTIC
ECONOMY CONTINUES, AND I SAY
CONTINUE BECAUSE THE BEIGE BOOK
THAT WAS ISSUED OVERNIGHT
SUGGESTS THE ECONOMY CONTINUES
TO DO RELATIVELY WELL.
DOES THE ECONOMY WARRANT A HIKE,
AND I THINK THE ANSWER FOR THAT
WOULD LIKELY BE YES, BUT THE
SECOND QUESTION IS ON GLOBAL
CONDITIONS.
DO THEY FACILITATE A HIKE, OR AS
IN THE PAST ACT AGAINST IT, AND
THAT IS WHAT THEY WILL BE
LOOKING AT AS OPPOSED TO THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
>> GIVEN WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW,
IS THE MARKET RIGHT AND PRICING
IN A FED RATE HIKE IN DECEMBER?
IF SO, HOW MUCH ARE YOU LOOKING
AT?
>> I THINK THE MARKETS ARE
CORRECT AND PRICING IN
PROBABILITY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
2/3 AND 3/4.
THE MARKET IS STRONG ON ACCOUNT
OF THE LABOR MARKET.
IT IS GETTING STRONGER ON
ACCOUNT OF AN ASIAN, AND IT IS
STRONG ON ACCOUNT OF THE ON IT
AND CONSEQUENCES OF ULTRALOW
RATES IN TERMS OF FUTURE
FINANCIAL STABILITY.
IT CANNOT BE DECISIVE AT THIS
POINT BECAUSE THE GLOBAL MARKET
IS SO FLUID.
I THINK THE MARKET HAS GOTTEN IT
RIGHT, AND AS WE GET CLOSER TO
DECEMBER, WE WILL GET A LOT MORE
INDICATION AS TO IF THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY FACILITATES OR ACTS AS A
HEADWIND TO A HIKE WARRANTED BY
DOMESTIC CONSIDERATIONS.
>> IS THERE A SENSE THE FED IS
OVER DEPENDENT ON DATA AND DATA
WHICH IS CONSIDERED AS LAGGING
INDICATORS?
>> I HAVE SAID BEFORE I THINK
THEY ARE OVER RELIANT.
BUT I UNDERSTAND WHY.
THERE ARE MAJOR QUESTIONS ABOUT
THINGS THAT ARE SO CRITICAL AS
TO THE LONG-TERM VIEW OF THE
ECONOMY.
ECONOMISTS STILL DO NOT FULLY
UNDERSTAND PRODUCTIVITY TRENDS.
THEY CANNOT EXPLAIN WHAT HAS
BEEN VERY SLUGGISH PRODUCTIVITY.
IT IS NOT CLEAR HOW MUCH IS A
MEASUREMENT ISSUE AND HOW MUCH
OF IT IS REAL.
ECONOMISTS HAD TREMENDOUS
DIFFICULTY EXPLAINING CORPORATE
BEHAVIOR.
WHY A CORPORATION HOLDING SO
MUCH CASH WHEN INTEREST RATES
ARE SO LOW, SO THERE ARE MAJOR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE LONG-TERM
DIRECTION OF AN ECONOMY.
HAVING SAID THAT, I THINK THAT
THE FED HAS BEEN OVER
DATA-DEPENDENT AND I WOULD MUCH
RATHER SEE A FED THAT HAS
SOMEWHAT OF A VISION THAT IT CAN
COURSE CORRECT AS IT GETS
EVIDENCE.
>> YOU ARE NOT BUYING INTO THE
ACUMEN THAT JANET YELLEN HAS
SOMEWHAT OF A VISION?
>> I WOULD NOT SAY SHE DOES NOT
HAVE A VISION AS MUCH AS I WOULD
SAY THEY HAVE BEEN TOO
RESPONSIVE TO HIGH-FREQUENCY
DATA, RIGHT?
THE RESULT OF THAT IS WE NOW
HAVE A MARKET THAT IS ASSESSED
WITH THE WRONG THINGS.
THE MARKET IS OVERLY OBSESSED
WITH THE TIMING OF THE NEXT HIKE
AND HAS NOT FULLY UNDERSTOOD
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE NEXT
HIKE COMES, THIS IS A FAIRLY
DIFFERENT CYCLE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A VERY
SHALLOW INTEREST RATE CYCLE.
LOTS OF STUFF GOES, AND THE
TERMINAL POINT IS WELL BELOW
HISTORICAL AVERAGES.
WITH THE MARKET SHOULD REALLY BE
LOOKING AT IS THE CYCLE AS A
WHOLE AND PRICING THAT IN AS
OPPOSED TO PRICING IN THE EXACT
TIMING OF THE NEXT HIKE.
>> I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
JAPAN.
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT IF IT
CAN GET OUT OF THIS FUNK.
DO YOU THINK IT WILL?
>> I THINK OF HAS THE ABILITY TO
DO SO IF THE THIRD ARROW, THE
SO-CALLED ARROW OF STRUCTURAL
REFORMS, WAS DEPLOYED FULLY.
>> THERE ARE NO SIGNS OF IT
HAPPENING.
>> AND THAT TELLS YOU THAT EVEN
A PRIME MINISTER THAT HAS A VERY
HIGH POPULARITY RATING FINDS IT
HARD TO IMPLEMENT SUCH MEASURES.
BY DEFINITION, THEY DISRUPT THE
EXISTING ORDER.
WHAT'S WORRISOME IS THAT THE
ULTRA RELIANCE ON MONETARY
POLICY HAS MADE THE BANK OF
JAPAN SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
INEFFECTIVE AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
BLOOMBERG REPORTED YESTERDAY
THAT THERE HAS BEEN THE LARGEST
OUTFLOW FROM JAPANESE EQUITIES
SINCE 1987, EVEN THOUGH THE BANK
OF JAPAN IS BUYING.
THAT IS NOT AN OUTCOME THE BANK
OF JAPAN WOULD BE HAPPY WITH,
NOR WAS THE BANK OF JAPAN HAPPY
WITH AN OUTCOME WHEREBY IT
SURPRISES MARKETS BY CUTTING
RATES INTO NEGATIVE TERRITORY
AND THE CURRENCY APPRECIATES AS
OPPOSED TO DEPRECIATES.
THIS TELLS YOU THE IMPORTANCE OF
MOVING ON THE THIRD ARROW ARE
INCREASING EVERY DAY.
>> HAS THE BANK OF JAPAN LOST
CONTROL?
>> THE SENSE IS THEY HAVE BECOME
MUCH LESS EFFECTIVE.
THEY CANNOT DELIVER OUTCOMES
ANYMORE.
THE FED AND THE ECB ARE STILL
ABLE TO DELIVER FINANCIAL MARKET
OUTCOMES, BUT NOT REAL ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES, BUT THEY CAN DELIVER
FINANCIAL MARKET OUTCOMES.
THE BANK OF JAPAN IS NOW HAVING
DIFFICULTY DELIVERING FINANCIAL
MARKET OUTCOMES.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU ADVISE AT THIS
POINT?
>> THE SAME ADVICE I WOULD GIVE
TO OTHER CENTRAL BANKERS, WHICH
IS DO WHATEVER YOU CAN TO MAKE
SURE YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY GAME IN
TOWN.
DO WHATEVER YOU CAN TO ENSURE
THIS MUCH PIVOT FROM ULTRA
RELIANCE ON MONETARY POLICY TO A
MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE MONETARY
FUND, AND IRONICALLY, WE KNOW
WHAT THAT ENTAILS.
THIS IS NOT AN ENGINEERING
PROBLEM IS MUCH AS A POLITICAL
IMPLEMENTATION PROBLEM.
>> LET'S TALK TO YOUR STRATEGY.
GIVEN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES, WHERE
SHOULD YOU BE PUTTING YOUR
MONEY?
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO BE MUCH
MORE TACTICAL THAN YOU'RE USED
TO, AND THIS IS HARD FOR
LONG-TERM INVESTORS.
LONG-TERM INVESTORS LIKE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CAPITAL AND
TAKE STRATEGIC AND SECULAR
POSITIONING.
WE LIVE IN A WORLD THAT MARKETS
HAVE BEEN SO DISTORTED THAT THE
VALUE LEFT IN STRATEGIC
POSITIONING AND PUBLIC MARKETS
-- IF YOU ARE GOING TO MAKE
MONEY IN PUBLIC MARKETS, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A MUCH MORE
TACTICAL BEND.
THAT DOES NOT COME EASILY, BUT
WE HAVE SEEN IN JANUARY,
FEBRUARY, THAT MARKETS CAN PULL
OUT REALLY QUICKLY IF THERE IS
SOME BENT TO THE EXISTING
PARADIGM.
>> WHICH ASSET CLASSES IN
PARTICULAR DO YOU LIKE?
>> WHAT I LIKE TO DO IS CALLED
CHARACTERISTICS, THAT IF THEIR
COMPANIES OR COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
VERY STRONG BALANCE SHEETS,
BUSINESS MODELS ARE ADAPTED TO
THE REALITY OF TODAY, AND AGILE
MANAGEMENT TEAMS.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS.
IN MOST OF THE PUBLIC MARKETS,
UNFORTUNATELY, THESE ATTRIBUTES
HAVE BEEN OVERVALUED.
SO IT IS A VERY SELECTIVE MARKET
.
I THINK RIGHT NOW, THE RIGHT
THING TO DO IS TO HAVE MORE CASH
THAN YOU WOULD NORMALLY.
>> WHAT WOULD THAT BE?
>> IN THE RANGE OF 30% IS WHERE
I WOULD PUT CASH ALLOCATIONS.
WHY?
IT GIVES YOU OPTION ALLEY --
OPTION AL AT A -- OPTIONALITY
AND ALLOWS YOU TO STEP UP.
>> WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSIGHT.
WE ARE COMING TO YOU LIVE FROM
THE BARCLAYS ASIA FORUM, AND
COMING UP SHORTLY, OUR INTERVIEW
WITH THE CEO OF BARCLAYS
HIMSELF.
JOIN US THEN.
ANGIE: THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT.
LET'S CHECK IN ON THE MARKETS AS
THEY ARE TRADING ACROSS THE
REGION RIGHT NOW.
WE SEE ASIAN STOCKS ADVANCING AS
CRUDE OIL RISES ABOVE 51 BUCKS A
BARREL.